take care of yourself okay
nothing else needs a piece
what is up everyone happy friday welcome
welcome to gamespot's live stream we are
streaming destiny 2 today and with me
i've got
philbo who i'm bringing their uh discord
volumes up right now so we got phil
hornshaw and john luke uh they're we're
gonna be the
the 18 fire team today
what's up
you guys excited or what man yeah dude
dude new dungeon day new dungeon new
dungeon day man it's like the only thing
better than the dungeon days and new
rate day right
so they kicked the seal onto the triumph
screen but
yeah it's all it's all question marks
they're all question marks but the uh
the seal name is or the title is uh
this desert is that how you say that
hang on i'm googling
let's find out uh
a person who pulls something apart
person who divides or separates
something so interesting
okay well i'm uh
i'm good to go
yeah sweet let me i'm gonna give one of
you guys leader you can just throw us
right in
uh i'm just gonna try to share this
stream to a couple of folks and take a
look at chat hello brandon hernandez
happy friday to you as well wolfmaster
charles goodman professor pyle drivers
we got some great
great aims here how you guys all doing
okay here we are speaking which let me
get that link up
we're doing master right that's where
we're
starting out strong we got all day
i actually super don't
all right
[Music]
so i jumped the gun and read all the
lore
all right all right you read all the
more already
oh wow
we're in the uh what's it called
the treasure room where you like yes we
are oh
caught it between my fingers and moving
it into a tapestry
one that i can weave you into
enter a calluses consciousness
oh we're jumping down y'all
oh hell yeah dallas's throne world let's
go
but it is not the one you know
your mind now stretches across a vast
gulf
the while this world is born of
callouses thoughts it is no less
dangerous than physical reality
damn i don't remember when his his brain
tried to swallow us during the leviathan
i think we got to shoot this thing up
here
oh
hello hey what up what did you shoot
the room
oh like yeah like a zelda like
switch i got you
yeah this is sick what the hell
yeah that's something on the seal
little cage yeah yeah look at his little
face
uh okay
shoot it again we're gonna shoot it kind
of a lot okay oh it's the bell that's
the bell oh
all right heads up don't shoot that too
much apparently that might uh mine
yeah no there's a bug no miss you if you
shoot that bell too many times oh really
yeah apparently it you can you could get
stuck oh no
basically just you can't toggle it too
many times gotcha guys
that could be our master mode basically
yeah
it's a good little challenge i got it
we're basically going to learn about
alice's past
yeah dude
all right it's some father-son or
father-daughter drama dude
very excited
to the future i must focus to maintain
your connections i'm just following you
phil actually don't seems like we're
just trying to make our way there
i have no idea
oh
that makes sense i just started climbing
and now i'm getting shot at so
we're on the right path
yeah
um
but yeah all the lore
is about callous and cuddle
and like when she was real young
nice so it's uh it's fascinating all the
guns and how she slowly got you know
more and more
annoyed with him yeah
kyle was kyle was instrumental in the
overthrow of callus and his exile right
um which is information we didn't get
till much later because originally it
was mostly about gaul um
but
gala
was helped along a lot by kaido
okay i see another i see the switch
across from us
oh yeah yeah wait till everybody gets up
here oh you're oh yeah yep
dope very nice interesting
so cool looking
it just creates like new pathing
basically
yeah
it's the dark world yeah you remember uh
you guys ever played was it like metro
prime 2 echoes with like yeah
yeah dude yeah
i think it was sick
beating my ass
yeah that or like twilight princess or
yeah nintendo loves that [ __ ] yeah
sugar's in the chat and she's talking
about kyle so she has daddy issues
oh hugely
hugely
yeah
oh oh
oh that's funny
what was that what's up
um we're too close were we not close
enough i'm unclear
was it a trap
maybe we have just oh [ __ ] all the way
down
all the way back
all right
we know what we're doing now
yeah so maybe you can't be close to it
um or you have to be yours right on it
yeah we were we were close to the okay
hold on we'll do an experiment we'll do
an experiment
what if we shoot it right now
uh let's try it
right away you have to i think you have
to be right next to it okay in the red
room you have to be beside it in the
regular version of reality you have to
be far away gotcha godzilla yeah versus
wrecked yeah man
okay good
okay maybe this like thing is like a
little like protector kind of in a way
you know
just that
to know good to know
hassan says hi there hello welcome
welcome to the stream oh man happy
friday
all right
let's do it
nice yeah
okay cool
we have to be in the bubble it makes to
with himself that's also the big theme
of uh
talking to him in the right season so
far
he is he wants to be darkness man but he
also is like
torn about it
he doesn't like the darkness
well he doesn't want to be evil
necessarily because he has like you know
ties to people gosh i mean
because in the like dark timeline he was
on our side yep uh if you remember like
it's like doesn't like uh heirs like
destroyed the leviathan in the dark time
of line
uh
i remember there's being something about
like the leviathan showing up and then
just like a bunch of pyramids like
absolutely destroying it or something
like that holy [ __ ]
a disciple and yes he wants he's all
nihilistic about the end of the universe
and stuff so he's
wants to be with
uh the witness but it's largely oh [ __ ]
i fell all the way down
it's largely because like
it's his weird ego thing right like he
wants to be
with the witness because he thinks he's
he's also a living god and should
be hanging out with the other living
gods but
the impression that you get is that like
he is also recognizing that we're
talking about the end of the universe
here right and
he's not super thrilled about that and
he like he feels guilty about kaidal and
stuff yeah so
he is
his ego is pushing him toward being a
bad guy
but he's not fully dedicated
i guess is what it seems like
so we're going to see
all of the oh my god
i never played warlock i'm sorry um
but yeah and so if you listen to
i think it was the solar 3.0 trailer
that bungie did they also talked about
how like this whole season is about
that sort of duality of people
and them
you know
we saw it with crow already you know
that's sort of being trapped between
two places and who you are and figuring
out you know being a good person versus
being a bad person right right
struggling with all that kind of stuff
so yeah that's what i think i believe
this whole dungeon is about hell yeah
i mean that name would imply
it is called duality everyone here yep
hey nice
right
red dragon says callus is just a wild
card who just wants to have pleasure in
life yes exactly exactly he's definitely
the wild card he can't that's what
always made him so much fun yeah
like vanilla destinies he shows up and
you're like
all right what's this guy's deal yeah
i just never know what his deal is
[Laughter]
yeah he can't like commit to an ideology
it's not like role crawl could like
really believe that [ __ ] real hard right
okay i see a one over here on the left
i'm going to shoot it okay
nice oh
spooky
i i loved vanilla
callus storyline of him just like
really growing fun to you and almost
like attached to you in a way like oh
you're so you're such a good little
guardian like why don't you uh clear out
this engine problem we have and so here
we go okay
right
yeah
and he doesn't need him for anything
really like
it's almost like he's playing like a spy
or something or he's playing like like
playing some kind of childish game or
he's like collecting heroes you know
exactly exactly
he does he's doing all kinds of spy
garbage he has no reason to really but
there's actually a bunch of lore about
this too because uh he would send
assassins so there's a he i think it's
the um
exotic sword that you can find in here
the story is that like it's an heirloom
that callus gave to kyle's mother
and it's been in their family for a
really long time and when kyle's mother
died or
unclear what happened to her um he tried
to give it to kyle and she wouldn't take
it she already hated him
and so after even after his exile he
kept
sending it to her over and over again
with an assassin and she would always
send it back with the assassin's head
[Laughter]
and
yeah there's a whole like
it's unclear if uh
sending her the sword was
you know like a gift or trying to stab
her with it right right right
so yeah it's fun good times good good
family dynamic yeah great love language
yeah
uh oh i think we gotta do a weird jump a
little uh yeah
all right next
oh
he was hiding in the corner he was dark
souls enemies yeah
all right
bubbles
nice
well uh over here
oh that was weird it like didn't take me
there for a sec
oh yeah
damn
call him out
oh interesting interesting yeah that's a
new wrinkle very interesting
grimm says that's a cool story indeed
man
their storytelling has just been getting
better and better uh dude it's there's
so much dialogue in the first week of
this
season
that's the big thing i try and like
convince people
like to care about destiny and it it's
still really hard because you have to
like get invested in all that stuff but
it's like
that story stuff is just so good yeah
yeah it's getting really solid
that's the first encounter maybe hoping
that uh
that's something you're hoping what i'll
just wait for him to talk oh gosh
is he talking about
oh maybe
i was hoping that's something that like
sony's uh they're like new being bought
by sony because sony's like a multimedia
company is like oh they could make like
a destiny tv show or like yeah yeah
other stuff that could like bring people
in
they i mean that is definitely the plan
so oh sure all right so there's a bell
over here behind us uh we have the
uh two axis symbol over here on the left
yeah the dogs is over on the right on
the right
let's go look at the front end of the
room i think there might be two more
there's another bell and then we got
weapons sun over here and chalice
chalice over here okay
and yeah two bells one at either end of
the room so that's which one do we wanna
pick
um that one's behind a wall so i assume
we you know are not supposed to know
about it yet i don't know
yeah let's try the front one oh the
banners to mark the uh the different
spots so that's handy okay yeah all
right
anyone saw the video about zavala having
a wife and son oh yes oh i haven't not
talk about it let's not talk about it
because i mean i mean
oh [ __ ]
i knew he had a wife because they hinted
that in some past uh laura yeah
there has been a little little little
bit of lure um about his wife this
leaked data mind cut scene from later in
the season
explains the whole story
of what happened with all that it's very
it's good
uh
such a bummer that uh those cut scenes
always get leaked because they're just
so easy to date mine and i'm always like
well no
having watched it it is not
so spoilery that like if you watch it
you're gonna be disappointed it's just
it's it's just a backstory piece oh yeah
there he is holy hell oh it's that guy
yeah run nice
so anyway yeah it's a it's a piece of um
it's a piece of backstory with no
context so right it doesn't it won't
like blow your enjoyment of it but
sure because it's like within that
there's always gonna be you know a bunch
of in-game cut scenes of all talking and
this and that exactly yeah
acquire standard essence
uh okay so these guys are called bell
ringers
bell keepers i got a worthy standard
essence
okay go to the war beast one oh maybe we
have to flip back to the other side
uh
he's chasing me where's the war beast
that was in my menus when
uh he is in the back right corner but i
think we need to go to the bell i think
we need to get to everybody
okay
ooh watch for snipers up here i see this
nightmare there's a timer this is
nightmare collapsing yeah yeah yeah
all right yeah get up here with me okay
cool got it do it
we escaped the nightmare okay cool there
you go all right so now you need to take
that dogs is in the back
how did you get that essence do you know
um i i was able to pick it up on the
ground
okay let's get this bell keeper
okay uh he is dead you dropped it a bell
is ready to be wrong
okay so let's bring another bell let's
try the one in the back here oh [ __ ]
hang on we're getting kind of overrun
real quick
uh we don't have to be close to it
ticket oh that's right right
so go ahead and plop it oh it's just
when we get out of the nightmare huh
yeah okay okay so i think the the two
bells are just to kind of give you
options yeah well because we got to run
from this gal round so oh yeah makes
sense
so i'm not sure if the if the thing
dropped from an enemy or i just found it
um
yeah let's run around and look at the
spots yeah
but it definitely is something uh there
is a nightmare bell keeper up here could
be one of these guys yeah i think we
can't i think we can't leave until they
are dead oh [ __ ] i got launched i got
you
uh
we are not limited in our revives by the
way yeah okay good that's the good thing
uh okay so the bell's ready to be wrong
all right we got 15 seconds oh acquire
this thing okay yeah i got it let's go
okay let's go uh it's the back one we
gotta go all the way to the back
that's sick run run run we're not even a
damage phase yet yep i see we have to do
all four yeah we probably have to do all
four
i have the chalice one by the way all
right do it let's go
nice
nice
cool running up to the front
there's no timer on the essence so
that's good yeah no no stacks or
anything like that
bell keeper up here
manifest standard okay did it
bell keeper died
all right cool i'm gonna send us back
okay
all right
oof
okay bill's ready
okay um i still haven't found it yet
yeah that's the part i'm unclear about
where they are yeah it was like off on a
side
area
yeah okay so not every not every corner
of this thing is open at the same time
so check the back check the backpack
i'll run
left and right oh i don't see it no
never mind oh we might have to just go
we got 10 seconds yeah okay um
we're going back to the
uh you guys might have to go without me
i don't think i'm gonna get there in
time okay go go go
no worries a standard bear has appeared
okay
and galran is no longer vulnerable hmm
okay oh was he vulnerable
interesting maybe we maybe we can dps
every time we put a standard yeah we
might have missed our chance gotcha
gotcha got it uh yeah okay
also didn't standard bears weren't they
if i'm
not mistaken leviathan didn't they like
take the relics that we would plant like
away
uh
you might be right
maybe
i don't know if they'll if they would do
the same here but just
because i saw it pop up okay so
the back rooms do open near where the uh
yeah
where the standard things are okay you
got the chalice oh sick okay yeah i got
the challenge uh essence uh we got two
bell ringers back here that i am dealing
with now okay
they are dead
all right so yeah meet you guys at the
front okay
yeah so we gotta go drop it off and then
we come back and then we damage him and
then we gotta do it again that's it
got it okay
okay right here
let's find these bell dudes
gal run shades return that's
okay yeah nightmare guys are spawning
dead
dead bells ready to be run let's bring
it
a nightmare overcomes you
he's still immune yeah
it's two maybe it's two at a time
maybe i don't know
try and find another okay yeah uh okay
got one back here i think
yeah standard bear got him all right
he's dead
uh did somebody did one of us pick it up
oh there it is
so we can head back wait john which one
did you get
you got the dog one
because i i got the dog one i don't know
if maybe you got it
i had chalice earlier oh okay
previously i don't know if it matters
gotcha oh i was just thinking if like we
were able to grab multiple per run or
something oh
i've only seen one so far gotcha gotcha
okay
uh i'm gonna go drop the war beast one
off
okay okay the bell guys are up
there we go
a bell is ready to be rung okay so both
we can clear both bells
because oh never mind
a nightmare overcomes you
ah
okay maybe we have to get all the all
the bell guys before we go
i had two bell guys at the front
with me oh
interesting
bill is ready to be run where's call ron
he's on me and car runs on me
still immune yeah we're doing something
wrong yeah have we well maybe we try
just getting all four first if possible
and then
we can the problem we only find one at a
time and then we never find the other
ones right like get the other one
whatever not here yeah
yeah um okay
um maybe we're
okay well we got 15 seconds yeah come on
okay uh over here uh emily
i'm coming to you guys now
i'm gonna get above i bet we can hang
out above it
all right i'm here
close galron is no longer vulnerable
what the [ __ ] okay so yeah he should
have been vulnerable during that period
did you just see this this door was open
and then it closed when we got here
really yeah um
when it when you plant the um
the little flag those doors open so
there might be something in those doors
oh okay yeah i bet that's what it is i
bet we're missing a step gotcha okay
so we plant the flag and then when we go
back maybe we check the area out in like
the other realm or whatever yeah we'll
know
yeah so before we go back in the bell uh
we should like check the door that opens
okay so bringing the standard into this
room opens the door associated with it
apparently okay and that's what i think
we're missing we have to come check in
that door of course okay okay i'm
hitting the bell
okay all right so we're looking for the
standard
a nightmare overcomes you i think we i
think we're missing a nightmare
somewhere i think we need to kill all
those guys
i think that just means you're in the
nightmare realm but yeah okay oh maybe
you're right that's what i'm thinking
uh bella's ready bill's ready
okay i haven't found it yet okay i
haven't found it either
um killing the bell guys
all right they're dead
oh here it is over in the left okay
no maybe not the store is open though
uh i don't see a guy wow this is like a
big room yeah that's the large one
okay i'm heading over to the bell we
have 20 seconds yeah it's got to be in
one of the rooms by the bell i think
because both the far rooms weren't there
uh okay
oh all four of them were open this time
huh weird oh uh standard bear was here
here i'm grabbing it it's accessible
oh hey that uh increased the time yeah
we got extra time oh really
yeah oh interesting
oh uh is there something else here
uh
oh weird oh there's there's a second
standard bear
oh okay
okay so wait hang on five seconds oh my
god oh my god okay got him ha ha oh okay
all right so grab grab that too and then
here i'm gonna i'm gonna run back and
check the uh
we only got 10 seconds i don't think
we've got time
but if i guess i guess we can wipe it
though yeah but i'm just seeing if i can
kill the standard bearer in time um
because it keeps extending you know what
i mean
yeah okay
all right so we'll we'll give that a uh
a shot although it didn't okay it didn't
wipe us it just
i i got oh nice oh nice okay i see i see
you soon
um but we don't have the
yeah we didn't make it back with any
standards no worries so i think i think
we can grab four standards at once it's
just maybe they spawn
after yeah like the first one you know
what i mean i think cascade yeah exactly
okay interesting so we'll all just split
and then play it up yeah okay um make
sure you s do you shoot out the snipers
grab the bells because uh those guys can
yeah yeah yeah okay yeah let's give it a
shot
okay two bears have appeared yeah two
standard bears
all right i'm going this way i'm gonna
go towards the ward beast
oh yeah i see him i see wine okay
okay
i'll check the other room
yep here's the second one nice
okay i got one
who's getting sniped though
okay i'm uh at the bell
okay i got mine
and picking up the thing
okay guys the nightmare withdrawals
come come over here yeah i'm coming to
the bell
oh boy i'm gonna die yeah push it push
it push it
and now we just need to check the rooms
yeah
i'll run shades return
call red shades return
uh
yes mine doesn't fellow is ready to be
wrong i'm killing the other guy that
bell is ready to be wrong okay yeah the
store opened
there's a loyalist uh in here yeah i
gotta hit oh [ __ ]
whoa
why did we transfer i have no idea oh
there's a ton of them
a shade of garam's defeated
he's still amazing
there's a bunch of visions of him
oh really
yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh in the room
in the room with me yeah oh okay okay
where are you oh you're locked in the
room i think i'm i am locked in the room
right now i can't get to you oh [ __ ]
okay
a nightmare withdraws
phil what was the other room that you
did was it warbies
it was war beast but i couldn't i
might have i'm not sure if i triggered
the bell accidentally when i pulled a
well oh gotcha
nightmare collapsing yeah let me kill
the belkase real quick
this one's ready
[Music]
uh cool we still can't hurt him uh is
this spelled ready i don't see it no
that doesn't really pack damn it now
we're gonna hose on the other side oh no
yeah bummer okay so when i went into my
room yeah um did you guys hit the bell
at all because i got i might have
accidentally i didn't
so i got pulled into the nightmare realm
there were a bunch of um like visions of
gauran that i had to kill
and i killed a bunch of them uh however
it didn't seem to do anything my theory
is
uh
two of us go into those rooms right
where the visions will be okay the third
person activates the bell locking us in
our rooms we each have to kill our
visions of gauran and then
uh i think that might trigger him to be
vulnerable okay that's okay that's my
theory all right i'm done i'm down to
test that out yeah so okay so whoever
didn't get this the when it's two
standard bearers whoever didn't get the
standard barrier is going to be on bell
duty basically they're going to be on
bell duty so like you wait for us to get
in our rooms we tell you we're good and
then you like activate the bell
sounds good all in
yeah i like it let's do it let's do it
okay
whoops
oh yeah
all right all right
hello
all right
damn i found one
i'm dealing with the bell guys as best i
can
uh okay okay i have dogs
we should buy another one somewhere
well it's nice that we got a timer
is there one in the other room next to
you it's probably in the other room next
to me and me
no i don't see him okay david you didn't
see one either okay so unless we just
wanted it just me must be just one this
time okay let's do it
let's go out
okay
okay
i'm heading over to warby's so all so
we'll do it with just me then okay how
that goes sure
um
uh we gotta find bellringer dudes
okay
oh yeah they got
the bell ringers
okay
let us let me know when you want me to
i just gotta get rid of this colossus um
okay go ahead and activate it for me
okay
oh it's
maybe i gotta
ah that one's not activated let me shoot
the back one okay
gotcha there you go very nice okay yep
i'm totally locked in here there's the
visions again
right okay
all right so yeah let's go clear the
bell dudes and be ready to go
uh i burned
snipers man thank you
okay
all right so two shades uh i got all of
them nice
are you able to exit at all the room or
no uh
maybe there's one oh there's one more
yes the room now opened
okay i'm back out
should we see if we can get another
standard i'm looking right now
we only got 20 seconds so yeah
runs in this room here all right let's
head back toward the other one uh
there's a standard here okay yeah grab
them if you can
all right back back
yeah the standard room stays open okay
okay i bet it's all four of them
um
okay there we go now the door open
uh i'm gonna go back in my standard room
and see if they respawn again okay
oh [ __ ] me dude
yeah there's a lot of guys out here
uh do you need help with your guys david
uh
maybe oh never mind gally just cleared
it you got it okay yeah uh i'm gonna go
on mine uh are you ready i am ready okay
hit the bell phil uh did we clear the
bell guys i don't think that we did hang
on yes we're just getting murdered oh
okay other side
i just stole a memory i don't know what
that means oh good sick that's the thing
okay
okay
oh hello
okay mine are still
uh dead i didn't respond mine are most
definitely alive
um what's interesting is there seems to
be a path between two of the doors like
oh yeah yeah like
like axes and the other section i don't
know what it is but it seems like i'm
able to travel between them
that's exactly what it is yeah
um okay my my gal runs are dead galron's
vulnerable
can you guys damage this oh he's
vulnerable yeah he is okay six six six
six sick okay uh we need to clear the
bell guys though and make sure we can
leave yeah yeah cause i can't i can't
get out right now i'm still
stuck in here
uh where even are the bell guys
oh here they are
i heard this oh
oh yep okay cool okay the bell's ready
all right hit him a few times and like
let's get out of here i guess
because we gotta leave
damn that is uh not much damage yeah
dude this is weird
okay ready yeah let's go oh [ __ ] it's
okay that's okay it was just a second
away uh
thank you
there's gotta be a way to do more damage
than that although to be fair i think i
was kind of the only one
yeah i mean i shot him a little bit with
the outbreak but i was worried about the
bell guys do we know yeah do we know
what makes those doors open
uh faster is it just killing the bell
keepers like getting the valve primed or
whatever
what what door open faster um well you
know how like after you you're fighting
the shades or whatever you're like
locked in there what what oh you have to
kill all you have to kill all of them
and then the door opens all the shades
yeah yeah oh weird okay i thought i did
and i was still locked for a bit
oh okay that's weird because
maybe my timing was just weird but the
second i killed my last one the door
immediately opened gotcha okay all right
yeah i don't know so it's either all the
shades or it's got to be like maybe you
just killed the bell keepers the bell
keeper maybe yeah okay cool okay um i am
ready
so i think the big thing is gonna be
timing it so that we're all able to like
do damage to him right away right right
right right
we got to kill the bell keepers like
immediately and then
so i think while standing back by the
belt are dealing with the visions the
person in the middle needs to deal with
the bell keepers right okay yeah i
pulled gel out i'm going to use that and
let's try it ready erase them
immediately
all right we're looking we're looking
we're looking
uh belgium
you found a standard
okay bell's clear
oh just need to knock it
i got a standard bearer in the back too
you got one two okay cool i think so all
right yep yep
he did that to me but i hit the ceiling
oh my god
okay i'm getting a little toasty right
here
really you know delrin decided to join
the fight
ah fun all right well i'm kiting him all
right i got my standard
sick uh tell me just clear and i can get
you back perfect
okay
now let's get the hell out of here
sounds like a plan
all right so you two have those
so i'll stay out ring the bell and try
to kill the bell keepers yeah
okay cool let's do it
all right uh i'm axes i'm war beast okay
sick
that means we will come out at the same
spot
um
which should be
useful bell bro dead
okay so on fire for some reason
waiting for door to open yep
oh
hold on
oh [ __ ]
uh can someone grab me yes one second
all right my guy's dead
all right oh steal memory yeah
if someone could just grab me
come in
my warlock is so slow right now
i gotcha
thank you thank you oh hey
dude those styles are
[ __ ] nightmare and a half
um yeah they are
you guys good are we ready i can shoot
from here all right
do it
oh hey one's right next to me
okay so i'm gonna kill the bell keepers
asap
okay bell keepers are dead
oh my god the girl runs have me caught
in a corner oh my god
it's bad it's bad this sucks
okay gunpowder so i died in there that
didn't work
that's all good that's annoying
so jean-luc's doors just opened i wonder
if
phil oh wait phil you're orbeez you guys
are not dead yeah i'm back i got
teleported out of the nightmare okay
um i can try to come back actually okay
sure
that's so annoying whoa um yeah my door
just opened so i assume that's because
again i killed them all yeah that might
be it yeah because
here's okay
david come over here you guys come back
and then you might just have to knock it
out you can just pop it okay oh my god
we re-teleported
okay okay my room i thought was
still open no it's gone damn it
yeah i think we gotta reset that okay
okay we good
uh
yeah let me get this right here too
okay
really
okay
all right i got one here perfect okay
mine's
i don't know if it's always the case but
they seem to be on the same side as each
other
yeah oh interesting
okay i got the word beast one again
nice
square
uh i got cup okay cool
okay we got lots of time let's go kill
the bell guys okay
man these snipers dude
yeah they're a pain
run beat my ass but uh it's the front
bell oh yeah activated it good
i tried throwing a healing grenade out
you knit like matrix moved around you to
mix
that sucks
all right pop it just go
shade dead
door opening maybe oh i gotta put the
thing down
oh my god there's holy crap yeah that
got real spicy for a minute
oh are you kidding me i got you guys
like the one dude
oh that's so annoying uh okay
my room is ready
hey i'm still clearing all good
all right
okay
okay uh
apart from these bell dudes shooting at
me i'm good okay do it okay
i'm pop here
all right all right
yes they were all next to each other
perfect
hell yeah
i mean that nice and easy
ooh gal run will do it i mean uh keller
horn will do it yeah
that's the move
yeah man
all right horn and uh gunpowder
okay shades of gold undefeated i'm out i
don't see the battle keepers
i'm looking for him now i'm out too oh
he's vulnerable he's vulnerable he's one
oh is he okay yeah keep keep going after
you keep going after the uh
okay okay
where is he
[Music]
uh it's the front bell i'm there
18 seconds so head this way
you keep shooting him as you go okay
okay
nice nice nice almost a third
and let's pop out
yep
excellent nice okay there we go that's
the rhythm yep cool
very cool i wish i could get some more
heavy but that's okay
so yeah it definitely seems like you've
got to do two sets of standards
per run
um to get him down jewel there when you
guys i'm gonna hide a little corner
defend me real quick i'm gonna pop on
some rocket launcher finders oh that's a
good idea i should have done that
try to get as many galleys as possible
okay bell's ready
uh yeah let's clear for a second see if
we can't get some ammo and stuff
yeah maybe i can cool
actually i think we're out of enemies
which one would i throw rocket finder on
that's uh helmet yeah help me that'll be
your helmet and then
let me see
i'm gonna do that too
uh riddle me this why do i have pulse
rifle targeting on
it's dude sam i've got
all my it's all my crucible [ __ ] on
right now i'm like okay cool
fighting galran with the fitting aspects
i love it
melee well maker no i think that might
be old
setup is it uh do you know which energy
it is for helmet um i think it should be
i think it's neutral like you could put
it on it yeah it's a neutral it's one of
the ones with the downward arrow yeah i
have it so it's yeah it's it shouldn't
have that it should be on you should
have it and then it's on this second
page
yeah
that's so weird it's not oh there it is
yeah
okay there's just 900 of them that's all
yeah
yeah it was just me being like i
i like totally moved past it several
times
okay i'm good
okay cool
all right you guys ready uh yeah yeah
okay i'm popping it
all right these doors are open in the
back but yep uh
yeah i think you guys have them i don't
think i have them okay i'm killing bell
guys yeah i'm gonna kill the scion and
then
john look i think you're right i think
they're always on the same side
yeah i think you're right too
um bella is set i'm gonna head back to
the back okay i grabbed my bear my
standard bear
on is here though
yeah as soon as i get there we can go
all right yeah roll out let's go all
right go
nice scott we're not doing it okay i'm
heading to chalice
uh what did i have oh i had sun okay
it does tell you which it's not yeah
that is nice
i was about to like yell when you guys
could read it for me from the foul
nonsense we have to try to write
[Laughter]
all right cool
oh we're all in the same place that's
nice
oop
i've got a little cooked over there
okay i am in my room
in timeout
almost i might have
put a grenade on the boil so
try to get in there if you can
i just gotta get my guy oh boy the room
gets spicy okay i'm ready
all right shooting
hello doll rounds
all right so it's gonna be the bell by
you guys uh i'm going to get the bell
keepers now
sniper definitely got me through that
column that's cool like that
bells are dead okay i think oh that's
all mine yep i'm out
uh i think we can damage him yeah he's
vulnerable
but head toward the front as you go
damaging him with primary feels great
yeah
i'm gonna put a well right here
although i hope it doesn't oh oh [ __ ]
oh god damn it that is my bad okay
do not put a well on the [ __ ] belt
yeah whale
[Laughter]
i thought he just killed me
all right you can go hit the bell
whenever you're ready
okay we don't have to be here for
anything
i'm supposed to be a healer and i'm just
making jealous collateral online well
whoa gal run
um okay i think they're on
the bell
i found them i've got none i think
they're by you yeah yeah they're ass i
just got one
i'm headed back to the other belt
because i'm getting shot up okay yep got
mine
yep got mine cool
oh i got a little cooked
okay ready yep
hit it
no i got shot
i got you
we need we need to take care of those
snipers like immediately yeah i gotta i
gotta switch out
weapons i don't know what to do about
them all right dropping my chalice in
okay unfortunately
i lost mine gotcha
uh so sean look when we go back try to
find yours and we'll try to
um quickly do another rotation i guess
yeah
because there's got to be a way to
recover if you only get one i think you
can do one at a time and then do a
second one so yeah
yeah
just take away longer yeah i'm in my
head i'm in my room yeah okay
okay fell guys are spawning at the other
end
no mine might have not spawned
it might be a different one now
all right bill's done
hope i did spawn okay cool
i'm running back to the other bell
because i'm getting wrecked
okay i got mine cool i'm coming
oh my god the legionnaire just body
blocked me
all right shooting the
psions uh when you get here to shoot it
yep
oh no there's heavy m over there
damn okay
uh all right i'm gonna do mine okay
do you guys want to come help me with my
door yes yeah i'm just clearing the bell
and then i'll come
okay all right
put me in chapter which door's horse
okay let's go ready yeah ready david
yeah i'm doing it
okay
nightmares at the other end yeah
i'm going to rocket them because this
sucks there we go
they're dead
we'll start popping those silence
other side other side okay
leave me alone
no no no keep following phil as long as
i guess
that's true all right
we got 25 seconds nails do it
okay well is not on the bell whoa wow
run good job
[Music]
yeah there we go there we go
okay head back head back
five yep get to the bell get to the bell
yep let's go
all right okay cool
all right we got the groove we got the
groove yeah we got it we got it
yeah we'd have more dps time if we were
doing two at a time i think for sure
so that's the trick that's the goal
yeah okay i will
see because both your standard bear
whatever nonsense would have piled up
together i think right right okay
ready i think we're square yeah
okay
okay not here
you guys search i'll just handle the
pillows
you just gotta look for the warbies
exactly exactly
oh jean-luc so i guess they don't always
appear on the same
side because i know
though is that they'll never be on the
same like
um hallway or whatever like i'm gonna
die
yes that is true like across from each
other or whatever
okay i got mine i got mine
uh bell's set okay which
uh
yeah
i'm coming uh it's always the opposite
of one or whatever one we used to come
in
interesting oh actually no
it's always the one that is yeah the
guys are at the other end go ahead and
go without me because i don't okay
gotcha grab you and i got it
yeah and actually we do always want it
to be the front one so that we can have
a safe spot stand
without gauran smashing us
oh my god god the ads in this area
are
a nightmare cooking me no oh thank god i
almost shot the bell all right i got my
room phil if you want to help uh i need
one second to make a switch no worries
i need a healing rift okay okay okay
okay
better
all right john look i'm here to help oh
thank you
appreciate it
all right he's dead i'm good okay
if we got time can i actually look for
ammo real quick because yeah let's clear
these guys
it's only have two
specials
yeah just be careful not to pop a bell
by accident yeah yeah
[ __ ] nothing okay i know right i have
one rocket thank you that's all good
okay i'm good i'm gonna start heading
back
yeah uh you guys should probably
actually be able to shoot it from your
room david um yeah i can shoot it from
my room if you so whenever you're set
just shoot it all right yeah you you do
it man okay um three two one poppin
okay
i'm gonna kill the bells
they're dead
and i'm just gonna chill at the front
and wait for you guys
this is
oh this sucks oh this room's a little
spicy yeah dude
i got like a bad i'm primary these
[ __ ] gol runs right now oh my god
at least they dude at least they dropped
a little nightmare buff
they do yeah
okay [ __ ] heavy thank god
okay i think i got i got rolled
all right he's vulnerable
uh
you guys can meet me at the bell okay
i don't know how much damage we're gonna
get to do on him yeah 20 seconds worth
i don't it's not like i have rockets or
anything anyway
dude the [ __ ] angles that go around's
taking this guy's like a guardian in
spirit i swear
five seconds okay
oh just go without me okay i'm here
dude i keep like there's like no blood
in my left hand
i feel like i need
the smg for add clear but i also need a
scout rifle to take out the snipers but
i also need something to do damage with
[Laughter]
it's a it's a it's a nice challenging
encounter for sure yeah i will say that
there's a better strategy to this but i
have not i don't have to like where with
all to figure it out right now
um that's okay there's no timer so we
can just take as long yeah exactly
okay going far side
all right i already found one
nice
uh
i think they're both at the top
oh snipers please
uh there's not a lot i can do right now
i'm away
okay um i don't see another standard
bear
fell silly yeah oh wait no no he was
hiding okay
okay i got mine uh i'm heading back to
the belt oh we've got plenty of time
yeah just give me one second get this
dog and then i can grab it
okay i got mine
okay
and pulling
okay i have
what happened why did i die
what
the [ __ ]
that that was a glitch that wasn't right
your toe is over the line so you get
killed by the bell i was like right in
the bell
killed me sounds like some battlefield
2042 [ __ ]
all right well
that's a bummer but we'll
we'll just do the one thing where you do
yours and then okay
i get mine after okay at least we all
three clear this room
yeah yeah exactly
well it's not working ah
well it's because we have all the ads
outside too
okay room is clear
david do you want me to actually come in
with you and help you get rid of the
vision sure sure that would be that'd be
huge that's a good idea okay
all right we're good all right so let me
grab this heavy and i'm gonna do yeah
actually hold on there's a heavy brick
right there is there one for me no okay
you don't get one
you're not allowed whoa right next to
you
dude that never gets old that just
scares me every [ __ ] time
yeah for real
okay
bells are dead
oh my god i'm gonna get oh one more
thing
nice thank you
okay
door should open oh did it scorch the
bell again god damn it
okay now we just need to find the uh
all right didn't okay we're okay
my well definitely damaged the bell but
didn't not too much oh thank you
over here by the bell yeah yeah yeah i'm
getting him i'm getting him okay cool
okay i got it we can go to the bell
i put this well here i think he was dps
all right okay
all right hit it let's go
don't kill me this time please thank you
okay
uh
come over to axes with me okay
actually phil if you have special ammo
or heavy maybe you're better served to
help john because i have no ammo
uh
and i do have three rockets so sick
then you can uh you can help clear uh
john looking all do snipers and bell
i was gonna say i could actually do it
on my own because the second i take care
of him he'll be vulnerable and you guys
should
a great call okay
i'll do it by myself and then you guys
like get ready to hit him sounds i
actually have a bunch of galley rockets
now so okay perfect perfect all right in
that case i am
guessing
uh okay send me in all right
oh wait let's do the front belt front
belt okay yeah
i think it's safer
oh yeah because he doesn't uh come up on
the front belt so you can kind of
exactly you can yeah we can hide from
that as long as you get the snipers
okay okay we're square go
yep i'm going to run back and galley the
bow guys right away okay i'm taking care
of snipers at top bell right now yep
okay down
all right they're dead i just gotta get
back
okay he's vulnerable
let's go
where is he uh he's in the middle
gauran you nerd
where's my money
[Laughter]
there he is let's go [ __ ] [ __ ] him up
good [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that's funny you were like [ __ ]
gloves and i'm like gloves
uh
are they they should be um
god they look like oh no it's master
forever they look so stupid or not
everest what are they called artifice
i don't mind them
they probably look cooler around hunters
but warlock's gloves look
i'm not yeah i'm not a fan of the um
branded i guess
armor sets from the dungeons
[Laughter]
although i like the hockey ones better
than the okay ones yeah
that was uh that was that was the thing
let me let me yeah let me
stretch my arm my hand out or something
sure did you guys find any more of those
stolen memories no i just found the one
what were those are those like
collectibles or something you know what
um here let me go back to a room because
there was a room where my uh ghost was
trying to like
give me a thing to scan oh let's check
this yes
oh yeah i thought i saw one too
i remember like in the middle of the
encounter being like what yeah yeah i
got a ghost ghost is looking at
something
yes yes it's
he's looking up
yeah yeah it's like these uh little
tubes up here
yeah okay
oh yeah
they're scannable there we go oh i can't
get up there i got it
i don't think they're kept checking for
everybody oh god damn it
hey playing warlock you guys oh my god
i was like i'm gonna change it up i'll
play more luck this season
what a nightmare
he's still scanning
uh he didn't do it he didn't say
anything
yeah it just came up again investigate
oh yeah maybe it's maybe it's a little
broken well
uh yeah okay weird uh there i can scan
two of them that's interesting i did the
same thing but he didn't say anything
yep
ghost
her memory curdles in my chest her first
laugh her first steps her first kill
poison poison poison
ghost is being kind of kind of creepy
just daddy
yeah
i'm gonna check the other rooms real
quick for sure
but yeah wasn't what was it
was it grasp no
maybe it was about something like
one of the recent
um
activities that was broken this way were
supposed to be giving us dialogue and it
wasn't um right possibly
uh i'm gonna grab some water real quick
you guys
be right back give me like 30 seconds
yeah it's just it's just the tubes
looks like
um let's check the triumphs oh nothing i
guess we have to finish it
hmm
oh i did get it without remorse oh
that's weird
mayor
all right
all right i'm backed and stocked up
okay let's go
let's do it keep going
ow
oh it's that
purple
purple can't remember what exactly
it's basically money wasn't it
yeah
other two there are two ways out of here
oh really here what's back here oh
well you guys go that way i'll try yeah
okay yeah
maybe we'll meet up in the middle
yeah it looks like they do connect
nice
lore things though there's got to be
some what'd you pick up jean-luc you're
glowing orange
i am
yeah
uh
i don't know i didn't pick up anything
phil are you seeing this
no
one's glowing
on on like does jean-luc is does not
look like he's holding something like
something stuck to his gun
oh
i totally see it on your screen i
literally have no idea what that is
that is that is really funny dude
look at the stream you can see it you
guys are going to make me sound like a
crazy person
like some eric andre show [ __ ]
yeah
yeah let me
it's playing an obi-wan trailer
hey man you gotta give us that ad
revenue
thank you for supporting gamespot
where did kelly say
uh he was talking about
he would gladly have laid to rest with
you
uh oh his wife i bet we were different
people so yeah i think he's talking
about his wife
dude he's got some okay some issues show
me oh yeah he is glowing even even this
far away
do you see it on your screen now i know
i saw it on i've got this this stream up
finally oh gosh it got some pictures
okay i found a thing i'm activating
very nice
yeah nice
snipers
whoa i missed
do you have a timer
45 seconds here i'm coming
[Laughter]
oh is to
lovely
thank you
okay put me up here
what are these
they're critics
looks like a muslim yeah that's that's
what his dialogue was saying oh so sick
thanks obi-wan
for making
thing
yeah so he wanted to be laid to rest
here with his wife or yeah implies his
wife's bodies here somewhere hmm
uh there's an activating thing here i'll
activate it
oh
yeah not great
at least he didn't eat us off the side i
suppose
scout for this
oh you guys killed him nice okay do you
know which uh what those activated i
have no idea i was looking around
it's back over there we have to go back
back where
uh the other side more of the little
yeah we're trying to get looks like to
this top one gotcha there's a there's an
open one at the top
there's also to the left
they opened up too
to left where let's check it out
oh you're right
maybe those are uh maybe they both lead
to the same spot again just like that
there you go
i'm shocked we haven't found lord things
okay this one has like straight up a
slide that goes down so okay
i'm gonna wait for you guys to tell me
what that is uh i'm gonna go here it's
like a little jump thing and it looks
like this has a slide
no is this lore
oh god where are you oh hey
uh do you see this thing
yeah yeah yeah that's a lower pickup
almost sure yep steel memory got it cool
cool cool i'm going to come get that
yeah if you want to come this way
this thing looks sick dude
all right did you guys just like have to
yeah let me get out of your way
sick
ah lovely
ah
we're actually friends with
callus what shocker
he was just using us that's what that
memory said that was a really cool
dialogue though
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
okay christ
yeah we do
that's not too bad
no it's okay
that was just such a funny [ __ ] way
to die
because i slit because i saw you die so
i was like oh okay oh well i'm dead
don't do that yeah i was like yeah don't
do that and then
i like i like tanked the hit and then i
just [ __ ] got kicked out right into a
piston and
or a crypt
yeah got my head [ __ ] sliced off
okay i'll go
activate this one i might be able to
just do it on my own nice
yeah good
cool cool
okay that was really quick yeah
all right
all right carefully
ow
all right
wow
oh no there's a hole over here
oh no oh damn
we have no way to get back to you yeah
that's fine just 50 or 30 seconds okay
cool okay just don't don't die
looks like one pathway out here
i bounced right into that and it was
warlock lighting so there's nothing i
could do but slowly yeah
sink to your death yep
it's gonna make me do that slide again
i'm bad at it ah yeah
do you have a rift or the phoenix dive
thing because you might be able to use
the phoenix dive to like stop your
oh my god it almost happened again okay
okay nice
dylan's asking what pulse rifle is that
this is actually a scout rifle that i'm
using
is
that
hungry
hung jury yeah yeah
i like it nice dude i was using um
duty bounds
so like it's better but after a while
like when we were doing the
the jumping puzzle i was like oh there's
some enemies far away might as well
i'm using the haunted one and i don't
have a great role on it yet but i do
like it generally yeah guns are so much
fun
i'm in the same boat
where's this
this feels like a thing
oh yeah
oh a new platform appeared
oh would you shoot together up here i
don't know if it actually i don't know
if it appeared or if it was always there
and i just couldn't see it okay
yeah make your way here there's a door
on the side
oh dylan i see you meant from earlier it
was
here i'm gonna crouch here so
everyone can go past i was using this
one insidious it's the vow of disciple
pulse but i crafted this one took me
forever and
got it uh got some enhanced perks on it
it's a nice one i might i love that i
love that pulse it's so yeah it's so
sick
well no
menagerie kind of looking area again yes
i don't think it's the menagerie but
it's very close
oh yeah
very close
and let's this is a tight room let's
change guns
also know if you've been looking at the
um
objective description text but you get
some
some stuff from kallus in there
nice
uh oh is there not there's not a rally
flag is there
no
okay well i guess that's not an
encounter then
okay ready yep yeah
oh here we go
nice
lovely view
um before we jump
well i guess it's not never mind okay
let's look around for another lord thing
real quick
so a lot of weird spots
oh my god i hate being a warlock
why am i so bad at it
okay so each of these looks like each of
these big bather statues has a callous
head on the back that you can push like
a button
really
yeah oh i see him yeah
bather statues the dudes with the axes
yeah the big the big axe dudes
oh i see what you're saying okay yeah
yeah
i'm gonna check behind all these big
columns see if i see one
you do yeah over here dope
i love it i love it when that works out
oh nice good eye
tell me more about your history kallas
mindless corpses of fallen
the only component that was missing
was a
nice
filling in what happened with pressage
yeah yeah so the agrigore stuff a lot of
the the lore in what we've found so far
in the season is about heiress doing
um experiments with the agricore the
that weird fungus
and apparently that stuff is like
a kind of like a conduit of darkness
between different locations
it specifically connects all the
pyramids together with the leviathan
it's and to a distant point which i
guess we can assume is probably the
witness wherever he is
so yeah the agor the reason for that
fungus and what the deal is with it is
that it's kind of a live kind of
darkness
i iris describes it as like the an
imperfect manifestation of of darkness
like stasis but like worse
and uh yeah it's it's some kind of weird
a live mind
meld link thing between all these
locations in these people so nice
interesting
yeah so there's a standard bearer uh or
a standard essence here you can like
place oh nice yeah it looks like there's
keep an eye out for that i'm gonna push
one of these buttons do it i know what
happens
all right i rotate it
and then i rotate it back and then can i
can activate it again so okay i'm gonna
activate one
i'm gonna let's see if there's any more
standard bearer spots or if it's just
the one
nothing yeah all the
they just kind of do the same thing they
don't really
are there four or three because if
there's three maybe we have to do it
there are four okay
uh maybe let's go back to the other side
and see
sure oh i gotta
turn back okay
i got coming
all right
all right see if they're buttons in here
uh these are also facing different
directions yeah they are they're also no
buttons okay yeah so yo oh what if one
of them is facing the opposite way what
if they rotate them on this side oh yeah
i think you're right i think you're
right
okay so
um let's just pick one and stand by it
before we shoot the the bell so you know
like which way you got to rotate yours
yeah like true north or something
okay yeah the question is where do we
need to rotate them i so i think they
rotate based on the way that callus head
turned i think they rotate one quarter
turn to the right yeah exactly
um so yeah just pick one i suppose try
to get them pointing in like to the
middle or something yeah that's what i
think yeah that's probably okay so
so mine has one rotation the one to the
left of me has
three looks like this one so yeah i
would need to rotate it three times that
i'd say this one and i think that one
also needs three yeah yeah
but then the one across from me will
need one i think or possibly three
okay ready okay yep yep
um i did not get oh no i did oh yeah i
heard it i heard it make a noise hear it
yeah yeah rotating once rotating twice
rotating
i think that one field needs to be three
yeah i think you're right
one
all right i got mine three times two
three okay
this is cool
bless you let's go back thank you
what's up
oh no i didn't
oh okay so that's incorrect they rotate
the other way the opposite way okay all
right so all of them need two two more
times okay cool
easy enough
so does that mean that they actually
rotate clockwise or counterclockwise
counterclockwise yep counterclockwise
okay because we were right we
just had the wrong assumption
i mean
it turns to the you know yeah
we were smart
[Laughter]
all right um yeah i got mine handled i'm
coming back yeah i got these two over
here
that's so funny
i made a big noise that time yeah
yeah yeah it sounded meaningful
boom yep
there we go
okay now what
wait oh
oh what is happening up there above us
above us
here's the encounter what is this
oh
yeah nice i love that oh okay oh [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
how did we activate that i don't know
but there was there was definitely a uh
a relic banner
yeah
yeah a rally banner or whatever so wow
this is a lot holy [ __ ]
all right let's just see how far we get
and then yeah
so we got two
uh
okay bell keepers over here
oh my god
hey there are symbols over here uh on
these walls okay
that go to the i think these doors will
open up
okay
uh my bell is active
or actually the opposite bell again okay
the one up the hit the stairs is active
do you want to hit it
yeah
bob jones what up perfect timing
okay
uh
okay don't fall in the middle
nightmare at the top never beckons you
those are what are these guys legionary
centurions
where the bell guys
oh
okay
i
don't see any dull guys
i found a colossus i beat them okay
uh
30 seconds we need to find the bells
yeah
this is a really big arena dude holy
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
uh
okay i found the cell a sun
marker
yeah okay these side rooms yeah okay
yeah yeah yeah the side rooms okay i'm
looking
five seconds honor colossus i wonder if
i revive jean-luc as we all die if it
oh no there's a
delay i was trying to brain time it but
uh
yeah let's rally first um
yes so yeah for sure
that was not purposeful
yeah for sure
right um
so you see these these uh over here
yeah
on the other side of them are symbols
okay and those doors are closed when
you're in the nightmare realm those are
open and they lead to those larger rooms
right uh and those also are associated
with those symbols
damn okay yeah sounds good all right so
first let's find the bell guys so we can
reliably get back and forth
let's see
what activates it what the hell
activated it yeah what triggered oh oh
okay i went near the bell that seems to
be gotcha the waking bells may ring once
more okay
okay also we have two symbols in the
middle uh axes and chalice i got a sun
on me right here
really
are we seeing different ones or what i
don't think so
god
uh
this area here oh bell keepers are down
here
yeah there's two down there oh okay oh
but we were having trouble in the
nightmare zone finding him yeah exactly
um so wait wait which way where are you
seeing your symbols david um right here
uh where i'm at it's behind this like
wall
oh no no i'm talking about the the
hologram one's in the center um oh i'm
sorry okay i see what you're saying yeah
oh no i crap i think those tell us where
to go right okay uh
axes and um and cup yeah chalice chalice
yeah okay so let's activate the bell so
that was
okay you guys go up i'm gonna hunt bell
keepers
uh
okay okay okay i think i found him yeah
i don't know which one's which yeah
those symbols disappear when we're in
the nightmare zone yeah exactly that's
sun
up at the end yeah
if you get to where they are
all right the bell guys are dead [ __ ]
it's the bell at the top of the stairs
so in 40 seconds be there
okay
there's just a lot of ads to deal with
there's a lot of ass very big arena
damn what killed me
that's weird
did the bell get damaged maybe
what no
i was okay but i was in the thing i was
if it had been the bell i was in the
ring
that's weird
but i
does the rift damage the
bell i don't think so it shouldn't
before we go
let's really damn it i was going to say
i really want to know which which one
yeah which one's which yeah well that
sun yeah make a map
dogs is over here so i would say um
oh my god
holy [ __ ]
okay so son dogs
so cup is r1
okay yeah use the stairs as the
yeah that's a rally point yeah stairs is
like the front so cup is our one okay uh
axis is r2 okay
sun is uh
l1 and dawgs is l2 okay
okay so that's from like this the
starting point gotcha see that again sun
is l1
yes dogs is l2
how do we unbox the chat one
damn it
uh go to your your settings film you go
to your settings and then under social
you're going to turn the text chat off
and then back on again and then i'm
going to get killed doing it okay
here i i can read it so it was sun l1
yup
uh axes uh or so no no sun is uh yeah
sun is l1 okay and dogs is uh
l2 okay
and then uh chalice is r1 and axes is r2
x is
r2 okay cool okay oh my god cool and
that and the orientation is from our
starting point which is our starting
point yeah which is the stairs or no the
steps no no the so if you're facing the
steps like you can see this the bell
step in front of you uh okay okay guys
like ron's down yeah yeah perfect
perfect okay that that's that's easy
okay um and we need to go get axes and
we need to get sun okay axe isn't so
let's do it
[Laughter]
i'm gonna try to track down the the bell
guys i don't think i can get david back
he's somewhere weird
i'm i'm in the other realm i'm in the
other realm
oh i see i see yeah so i just don't be
standing in the middle when the bell
gets
uh transferred over i guess holy [ __ ]
blown up
there's too many guys this is all
together there are way too many guys
also
they gave us
this armor thing
that's solar and void but everybody in
here has arcade
[Laughter]
it's ridiculous
that's actually a good point let me put
on
okay yeah yeah i found my standard bear
cool okay cool
um what was the other one
um
oh nightmare
it was axes um
[ __ ] sorry i didn't get in time okay so
you have to kill all the enemies in that
area and then
the guy will spawn kill him
then he can grab it
got it that's a lot of dudes to kill
though
so so the standard bear only appears
would it appear anywhere when you clear
the ad so we have to just make sure
we're clearing the right spot or
um that's a good question i would as
i don't know okay well i mean to be safe
we'll just go where we need to go in
where we're supposed to yeah okay yeah
uh
sick nice
okay uh if i can just stay alive out
here i'll handle the bell
while you guys do the run
okay cool cool
this room scares me man i swear dude
what is activating it really
hello
what is
how out of the activated each time like
now we started
okay uh
dogs and
axes okay so that is l2 r2 cool
oh my god ads get the [ __ ] out of here
holy [ __ ]
stair spell is good to go if anybody can
shoot it
uh
all right i'm getting there i'm getting
there i just
nice okay all right i'm going to l2 or
r2 you're going r2 okay then i'll go
all right
all right i'm going l2
oh guys tend to be underneath the
the lower bell if that makes sense so
many ads that's where i keep finding
them
[ __ ] i guess probably because i keep
activating the top bell
there's so many so many dude
okay okay
yeah arc resist is the key oh my god
ah dude
all right i got
i got my boss yep
all right come on we got plenty of time
if we can just stay alive
i'm getting pummeled though dude i'm
getting [ __ ] and destroyed holy [ __ ]
okay okay
uh where do i meet up with you guys i'm
just in the middle top of the stairs top
of the stairs okay
okay i'm here holy [ __ ] dude take his
bullets
get me out of here
yeah it's not gonna be much better out
here
all right go drop your standards in the
middle and see what happens okay okay
popped it
okay okay looks like these guys are
damaging
oh the nightmare guy is definitely
damageable
sworn of what's his name i'm shooting
yep
all right he's almost dead
oh we got a new nightmare now
yeah uh we and we got more symbols now
so we need to go again sun and cup
chalice all right uh find the bell guys
okay
dude
this is like chaotic as [ __ ]
oh my goodness
all right i found the bell guys they're
underneath the stairs
uh i've got another rocket
there they go they're gone
okay you said sun and cup
yeah so that's gonna be the ones right
yeah yeah l1 r1 alright i'm hitting it
do it don't be in the middle
all right oh no oh i died i don't know
how though it's weird
that feels like a glitch again yeah
okay so i'm gonna go l1 phil you might
have to go r1
yeah because we're short on time um okay
i went ahead and killed the bell guys r1
is where hang on i got it uh yeah from
yeah
so
pull it yeah just versus the standard i
haven't been able to kill myself yeah
just go okay
oh no
damn this is wild man yeah
i think timing on these is rough yeah it
is
gonna be really on point
uh
oh my it did keep our other ones which
is good nice so we don't have to restart
yeah we made progress we're doing good
um but yeah we should just same thing
uh yeah we gotta reset the bell
oh yeah sideways
ah i'm coming
the other bell guys next to me
okay cool
uh ready to pull
uh we get the other one yeah
okay
i'm pulling us yep do it
l1r one yeah
yeah yep uh i'll go l1 okay i'll deal
with the bell bros cool i'll go r1
there's bell at the top of the stairs
again
uh oh no wait that's not right sorry i
went the wrong way i got mixed up
did you
yeah i was in sun which or no am i
supposed to be in sun yeah yeah sun's
one of them yeah okay oh okay be quick
though 30 seconds
uh yeah mine's just here i didn't have
to
i only had to kill the colossus so okay
oh nice
oh okay yeah sorry that's my bad
i got confused i am 15 seconds yeah i'm
running asap to you as much as i can oh
you got we just got a reset so just
quick get here quick oh we got to reset
okay cool yeah well
oh god just not not a huge one but a
little bit oh i hope i didn't damage 15
seconds
i'm running i'm running i don't think
you're gonna make it i'm on the way he
will he will he will come all the way he
will he will he will oh my god come on
you're
[Laughter]
all right yeah [ __ ] this guy up awesome
oh he's mad
he's pissed pissed
oh my god
there's nowhere to hide
i just get immediately pelted
uh i'm gonna go get him yeah yeah
i'll try and hold the fork
i guess
oh he's chasing me it's so scary
here i got another well here
nice oh thank you yeah wells are like
critical here
oh god rocket spirit yes
no
all right he's almost gone
hell yeah
something clicks within the vault door
very nice another guy showed up and new
stuff it's we're slowly opening this
door
[Music]
so okay it's now axes and chalice axes
jealous okay
uh just need a second to clear i'm
getting chalice r1r2
r1r2 got it
okay okay okay
bell bros got him
no no oh my god
all right can i hit the bell
uh one second
all right square go for it yep
stay away from the middle
okay i got our one you got our one i
will get r2
all the music oh girl yeah okay guys
it's gonna be a different this time it's
gonna be the low bell not the high bell
okay
got it
didn't have
okay
bill's set
i'm on fire but otherwise good oh sorry
all good oh my god
uh just do one
and let's teleport back because we're
not gonna have time yeah yeah that's
smart
god that's my bad oh you're good
it's cool oh no
no oh phil
i keep miscalculating how to jump
20 seconds david
uh
all right we have to do another round
though yeah no worries
uh which one did i have axes okay here
we go popping it in
bell keepers
okay bell's down
do it need to knob hang on let me not
get cooked okay
good to go
whoa that was a weird visual glitch all
right there it's gonna be the top nail
again
this time opposite bellows last time
bell's clear
cool
and the dude had a
shield
oh thank you for helping yep
get here fast because we have a shorter
timer
okay
got it sweet let's go
all right
we're clear as soon as you guys get here
yeah
nice work
nice okay drop it well in the middle
okay after you guys after we hit the
banners sure
i think this is the last one you guys
yeah i think so nice
do it
damn
watch these guys jumping in trying to
block our rockets
oh my god as you said that i swear
yeah holy [ __ ]
i can't even make that up
that happens to me all the time yeah all
right second well
nice
[Music]
dude holy [ __ ]
he's mad
we're going to go down in his brain he's
not happy about it
yeah yeah where is the chest
there's over here hey i got a gun
oh nice what did i get
please give me a gun please linear
fusion let's go please give me a gun oh
i got a linear too [ __ ] i got the
bond
you got the bun
dude the weapons on the they look so
good though
i love the i love that design dude this
original trade bitter spike while this
weapon is equipped taking damage
accelerates its next reload
it's kind of cool yeah
oh wow that's cool
causing damage solar ability weakens
champions for a short duration that
sounds good i might take that shining a
champion causes it to ignite that sounds
good
i mess with that
i'm gonna put on
i'm gonna [ __ ] around with osteo for a
bit for those ad clears i wonder if
that'll that's a great idea that's a
great idea if that'll actually help i
mean and mainly i mean gallo horn is
perfect but i also want to like mess
with the new fusion rifle a little bit
or linear so
no i like that i'll keep i'll keep
galley you do that um that way if you
want to go back to rockets you can still
get wolf backs yeah yeah
uh
that's a great idea here we go
rock this warlock pond i guess
that's good now that we know how it
works i feel a lot
better about
doing it
you know
yeah yeah that was wild
gosh that thing looks sick god damn
so good
i love how it feels like with val they
were like you know what let's
lean into the guns being really
weird and moving and stuff and now it's
just that's just the idea
from now on everything glows and is
weird and
it has teeth and whatever yeah
just infused weapons
absolutely let's make them spin
big fan
that's gonna be cool man
okay says use the origin mod yeah man
i'm hoping so
let's see what happens let's go let's do
it
and we haven't even
have
have we run into champions i guess no no
no no champions i don't know why you
said that just now putting that energy
out in the in the i'm sorry
i'm kidding i'm kidding so what happened
was i opened up a new artifact mod whoa
i was trying to figure out which one i
wanted
these are encased the same way they were
in the pyramid and they yeah yeah oh my
god like all around guys
up in the up in one of the rooms earlier
it was uh
like cloning tubes yeah remember i'll
take the left okay yeah i'm checking the
right look for lore i'll just uh
follow one of you guys
uh
up high maybe
maybe one of these tubes it's really
dark though it's all very dark
i really can't
overstate how happy i am that this
leviathan dungeon has like different
areas
than what we do yes very good
i'm really glad yes also i'm really into
the idea that we're just like this is a
whole callous
mission right it's not just it's not
just about callus it's about callus
that's the stuff in the it's like fusing
with the pyramid architecture oh my god
you're right
phil come look at this when you get a
chance after you're done
yeah
okay coming
i don't think there's anything out here
dude look at this [ __ ] yeah the darkness
is in his brain dudes yeah
hell yeah
uh new text just popped
yeah the depths
navigate the vault cut it away a knife
through memories flash peel back when i
what i was and replace it with scalding
gold
i do not want this i do not want this i
do not want this ah
he's losing uh
dudes up high
uh over there phalanxes oh i can't mark
there you go plug it in
oh what is this oh some sort of darkness
artifact
in the middle here oh
very nice
it's got like a
big sheet over it
here there's a belt
hang on a second
getting it up
i don't think i can it's like a bed
chamber or a pallet pelican
i'm gonna shoot the bell
okay you all ready uh yes
uh we would have got a rally flag if we
had to worry about it so yeah
nice just fell off the edge that's a big
hole okay uh it looks like there's that
over there yeah looks like there's a
little pathway here
[Laughter]
uh
i think we are climbing up
coming back and climbing up
climbing up
yeah
seems to be the case
don't go from here
can we shoot a bell from here no we
can't
well we'd have to be yeah we'd have to
be on it
oh i found it
nice
uh i'm not getting it there we go symbol
yet so
are you going to keep going i'll i'll
see
i mean if it tells me to turn back then
oh weird i don't even know you could go
over there
don't find a lure that would be really
frustrating
i went too far and i fell
here let's go back
to the other side and see if it puts
them close to us
oh sure
ah on the other side of this wall damn
well you guys clearly found the the
right way
uh we can't be separated like this can
we i don't think that's a good idea
uh we'll see we'll see where it puts me
if i respawn oh it just puts me back
where i died so let me all right well at
least you're in the nightmare now yeah
but now the question is am i able to
reach you guys
um we'll just anna you're gonna have to
[Laughter]
this just this is a bad spot for my
ghost dude
oh yeah you're like way over there yeah
um well
i guess we'll just probably keep going
[Laughter]
sorry
i don't really know what else to do
about it
oh this like trapped us oh no no up top
oops
i wonder if there's a callous bobble
head in here
right
almost definitely
although ah actually no because
um if the bobble heads are tied to the
seal technically you don't get this
dungeon for
the season oh good call yeah well
actually they probably don't go for it
all right well now i'm spawned
back in
oh yeah i see you down there yeah
uh let us get to wherever we need to be
in the before you yeah yeah before i pop
the bell
hey there's another one of these uh
standard essences this has to be for
something related to like the exotic or
something yeah the exotic quests i bet
because
yeah yeah they gotta be
um what's that hang on
oh i heard like a little bell noise
that uh
what is that
do you see something over there
yeah let me see if is that something
real or something fake no it's a dead
never mind it's a dead body
okay i was able to jump to it at least
um
okay oh well whatever doesn't seem to be
anything here
oh [ __ ] this is a hole
be careful when you jump over that
oh i think you got through
yeah we did
enter the dark shrine
for once in my life i do not feel shame
i feel the caress of a thousand
hands hear the comforting hush of a
thousand voices do not be afraid it
whispers we are your salvation yes
please save me for myself oh nice if i
pop this bell is it gonna take you guys
to into the
uh that'll be an interesting question
that you should uh i don't know how if
it does we're probably gonna die
immediately so go ahead and try it
yeah
since it didn't i otherwise might be
able to pull you soon yeah no i was
about to say so i'm in the in the
darkness zone yeah no we're fine yeah oh
did you survive i died immediately
so really i'm i'm alive
oh man that's funny i just
do you guys have this like
and then it just killed me yeah we're up
by the bell above you so just go ahead
and do what you got to do
uh
okay
so go that way climb up to the next one
above you okay and then turn around and
go back
and turn around no i'm sorry no there's
no there's actually the path is ahead to
the right sorry
where you went last time see it there
should be an opening above you to your
right i think yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah it blends with the
wall
okay cool let me
[Music]
and then
i'm just gonna wait for you to come
revive me because we're next to the
other bell so
okay or i am anyway i don't know
revive and see what happens oh it put me
uh here
now we're at the uh
well he's gonna do it again though
[Laughter]
oh yeah i gotta
well let's see where we can get to
i gotta get a longer range
oh my god again
oh thank you oh phil where did we spawn
you
i'm not dead
i'm oh you're in the other world okay
i'm like i'm broken out there bounce
basically all right now i'm dead
nice i'll be real this is a little
annoying yeah
like one person gets like stuck behind
and then it's just like kind of prevents
everyone else from moving forward yeah
all right
we're all we're almost there though
sick
sick sick sick sick
oh now mike
really really really good what happened
we both
those physics
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah i'm watching the
stream so it hasn't happened yet
you're about to see it
okay good thank you thank you all right
well good okay this is where we would
have been if we had slid down without
dying yes yeah cool cool cool cool
so i guess that's the the solution in
general if somebody gets
behind you just wipe at the end and pull
everyone
the warlock jump is the worst
oh my god i fell off
okay
did you just jump across the oh i see a
little mini plaque yeah on that yep
perfect
this place is sick
so i'm saying what's the new hunter
helmet called uh is there a new hunter
helmet
is it an exotic
uh i mean there is one in witch queen
there is a new set of exotics
uh the exotic it's the
gloves though yeah calibrance
is that a path
i'm gonna check it out
okay
this looks suspiciously like a platform
but i don't know where i can go from
here can you make it there
it's a long way
[Music]
hey like i must have like the wrong
warlock jump on because
i'm not maneuverable
you find anything
nothing yet
um i think we could go along the edge
here
and go further away
can i drop down is that gonna kill me
i can go pretty far
this way i'm gonna go check it out
uh nothing yet
i can like go down but i'm afraid if i
go down i'm just gonna end up
oh i'm dying
yeah yeah
yeah i'll get you
okay i'm at the last
the last platform
it seems like
nothing yet actually there's one kind of
off in the distance still
oh no invisible wall no okay okay
bummer okay i'll head back over
to the
all right i have to kill myself
damn
oh yeah that would be why
burst glide
that orbs and then uh
yeah just leave me okay
all right here we are
next encounter
oh sick you're pulling us perfect
oh you gotta fight kyle
oh
that's sick
that's great
cuddle's got some sick armor coming out
of here
okay so
i got the dog hologram okay yep
and the chalice hologram
okay belzer uh where are those okay okay
look uh if you look to the left and the
right
gotcha yeah elevated yeah yeah okay
l1
start writing this
yeah they are different sun is l2 dawg's
l1
suns l2
uh r1 is chalice r2 is axis
chalice is r1 you said
yes and axes r2 r2 okay and it looks
like there are three bells two on the
side one in the middle cool
cool all right that's gonna be your
dating
uh what are the ones we have to
um what are the dogs dogs and chalice
dogs
i'm hitting the bell okay so then it's
the ones
okay
okay i'm going to uh i'll find the bell
guys
i'll go r1 oh yeah
it's right here so
yep
already got him got it
oh i'm getting wrecked a little bit oh
thank you no problem
uh so it's gonna be the opposite side
it's gonna be the left side bell okay
over by dogs
or maybe not
i think it's the middle bell
yeah it's two sets of bell guys
oh i blew myself up uh kill that other
bell guy if you can
okay now it's the middle bell okay
let's go
uh watch out for the colossus
at either end of the room oh god one
second
okay oh [ __ ] me oh i didn't realize you
were sorry that's okay
i saw everyone there and i was like
i got greedy with the ammo
um
okay i'm gonna just activate dogs see
what happens okay
music changed
nice oh david here you are
wow
sucks
oh wow i got immediately smoked
okay so
we still gotta get cup
yeah okay
in this uh
in this encounter it's snipers and void
damage
got it largely all right
sending us
uh
before
oh my god
all right oh here's yeah standard bears
are the snipers okay
oh my god
i got killed
is there another standard bear
i saw him oh yeah there is another one i
don't know why though because i already
activated it oh there's standard bearers
elsewhere too so maybe it's just like
you just got to pick up the right one i
think you just got to pick up the right
one yeah we got 10 seconds we got to
kill these uh okay fell guys yeah now
where are they i got one there are two
in the middle belle is ready to bring it
is this one on the left oh
[ __ ]
uh well i made it out anyway that was
just a second i was gonna say maybe we
just reset yeah let's let's wipe
and rally
to the
uh where can i die step on me cuddle and
there we go
you said it was void
void inside uh yeah i think this that um
centurions are shooting void okay i
don't know what the the scions have but
they're snipers yeah for sure add kydel
has solar so i threw the um i threw the
armor of the dying star back on
okay the the seasonal one good to know
just give sec
this is a big giant bell in the middle
if you notice
this must be the actual bill of conquest
he was talking about
also if you recall the bell of conquest
was the seasonal artifact from the
season of the um chosen yes
neat
anyway
that is
okay
we need
oh whoa have you shot the linear uh
david uh no not yet it's it's uh a burst
fire
what
what that sounds excellent oh it is a
burst fire weird
all right one set of belly guys is dead
all right we got dogs and we got um
i think it's axes yes dogs and axes
the non-snipers scion shoots solar so
yeah you want the armor the dying star
mods
l one r one oh sorry no l one r two okay
ready yep
taken us i'll grab r2
all right got it
oh my god i immediately got killed what
happened
here i got you
thank you
all right all right apologies
uh one set of bells just down all right
i got i got dogs
okay i got axes other set of bells is
down the bell we in question is the
middle one uh yep we're good
yeah i'm good to go uh give me a second
running in now okay yeah let's go
incoming colossus fire
nice that was fun
knock out those snipers if you guys can
yep
[ __ ] oh no oh no yeah
i got a clear butt
yeah i just i i dropped my thing too so
i'm good
it's kind of damageable no
i bet we have to do all four four yeah
uh okay next is cup and sun
so
uh that would just be the other ones
right r1 l2
yeah i think so yeah okay
okay i can grab l2 when we
let me go
okay ready yep yep
okay all right
got l2 oh my
[ __ ]
[ __ ] colossus i swear i think i uh he
got a sniper got me unfortunately i
grabbed my thing and then the colossus
just rained hell on me
the bells are down i believe yeah the
bell is red
you guys can just ring don't worry about
me
all right
i can get you okay
that works to
run away from the colossus
okay
yeah the class is rough man i don't know
a theory
okay ready
yes
square
all right got it okay uh one set of
bells
looking for the other i see him
on the ground oh i'm on the bell right
now okay i'm coming to you
all right okay do it yep let's go
okay cool
thinking
oh my
okay all right you're right yeah yeah
i'm fine i'm kind of fun just gotta
this is so gnarly i'll get me banked it
paint it
conquest is primed whatever that okay
uh shoot these shoot these chains shoot
these chains
okay
yeah
it seems like they're immune
oh here yeah okay
oh why are we here we get here it's
vulnerable okay
uh kill the bell guys quickly i'm gonna
do them
all right belle's ready to be wrong we
can leave when we're ready okay
actually she's standing by it
kyle is withdrawn okay
oh i barely got to do any damage yeah
yeah i don't know i didn't get to do
anything
i hit her with like exactly one rocket
so maybe it's the amount of times we hit
the
the things that will extend our dps
timer or something
i don't know i don't know
okay there were four chains shoot but
they were immune the moment i tried
shooting them
yeah they were glowing red and i shot
one and then it moved and did it and
that and then we were in dps that was
really weird yeah okay
i wonder if killing the bell guys is
what
kicked us out
or if we just actually accidentally
activated a bell
maybe from other fire oh i don't know
because every time before now we've
we've needed the bell to be ready to go
right yeah okay i'm gonna activate the
bell uh we know yeah our symbols are sun
and something else axes sun and axis
okay cool
so that would be um l2 r2
l2 r2 got it
i got r2
or you got r2 i'll get l2 uh okay cool
all right got it
got it as well
uh one set of bell guys is down but
still working on the others
yeah i'm helping
all right they're down
that's gonna be the middle bell okay
okay
i'm here
yep one second okay go
where is the [ __ ]
oh it's over there
oh the scions man
so brutal
brutal oh yeah
okay i banked mine though
cool
i'm getting wrecked
yeah i just got sniped out
damn
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna swap off of
well because
i think that
i'm going to try to add clear yeah
sounds good we need we need better ad
clear yeah i'm going to try to go out
clear i'm wondering if stasis will help
but i'm also worried stasis might [ __ ]
up one of the bells or something
i'm going to get off the line here and
go back to galley yeah i swapped i saw a
machine gun osteo's been doing fine for
me but
yeah i that linear was not an ad clear
linear
no
i feel like rockets is the is the play
here for sure
absolutely um okay let me see
yeah it's either gonna be stasis or void
i think is what i'm leaning towards
and then i'm gonna swap
i'm gonna put on instead of knoll i'm
gonna put on that solar fusion for those
um shields
i like that it's good too
okay okay so i got cartesian on i've got
yeah [ __ ] it i'll just put on uh where
is it at duty bound get gallon back
and
bob jones 1980 says the title face had
no nightmare countdown do you mean the
uh the dps face
i think he does like it wasn't gonna
kill us in the nightmare like it usually
does maybe that's maybe we should
maybe that was the trick and we we ended
it too fast or something
maybe
hmm
okay
i think we should like on that phase we
just need to get like a well or
something in the middle and
yeah yeah for sure
um
yeah i think we've pretty much got it
under control we just got to figure out
how to do the dps part
[Music]
okay okay then yeah i think we probably
killed the bell guys too fast
so i think maybe that's the thing is
avoid killing those guys
which could be fun it's gonna be a lot
of
i'll put the wall down
let's see
uh
billy's final void
okay
champion mods because we don't need them
what's that one yeah
that does the uh oh i'm gonna put on
devour for sure
so i can get heals
and then defeating weekend targets
finishers
and fizz
where's that one that
grenades weaken people
because that's
gonna help with dps
there we go void grenade's weakened
targets perfect
put that
okay i think i
i like the setup and i am
good to go let me just rally here
do i have the rocket launcher
ammo back on
all right
got my tinkering done
quick i'm good to go
yeah i have not really configured my
mods well
i think bob jones is right though yeah
once that dps happens we just like
maybe stray away from the from the bells
for a second until it's like
it could have been a case because i know
she moved in front of the bell we might
have just shot it by accident yeah the
rockets aren't
great
necessarily for that situation well
we'll see let's get to it again it made
it sound like she ran away from us
if that makes sense right that's kind of
what i thought too yeah okay
all right squared up
all right
yep i'm ready let's do it
yeah i think i think one thing to try to
pay attention to too is what those
chains did and how like why they were
immune and stuff when we get there all
right looks like it's dogs and cup
so that's l1 and
r1
got it
i'll take l1 okay
okay i'm ringing the bell okay
all right belle keeper's in the middle
and on the left
so it'll be the right bell i grabbed
i grabbed mine got mine yep
i blew myself up god damn it
i can get you
oh maybe snipers man yeah yeah yeah
they're rough okay all right let's build
all right let's get it
uh come in
we got last time
all right come here
pops out
we're all shooting at enemies
i think we just looked at that sniper
all right okay i got cup banking it now
all right
whoa i see i don't got me
the other bell guy
in addition to the first guy bell guy
blowing up uh
are we good to go again uh i believe so
yes it's dogs and axes yeah dogs and
axes wait we already did dogs
uh dogs were still popping up
what yeah
okay that's fine uh maybe we could just
roll back if you want
oh my god no we're gonna try
hey i'm getting david
also i'm totally gonna get
killed
thank you
all right i got dogs again
uh what was the other one axis yeah
yeah his axes l2
uh r2 r2 r2 okay well i'm dead again
[ __ ] hell dude maybe we need to get
we need to get out of here now yeah
okay here you guys you guys get out yeah
yeah uh where is it middle one middle
middle okay ready yep
uh
oh yeah right again okay
that's good to know that it can be the
same symbol
uh also i've noticed the other two bells
disappeared so i think you only have
three chances to do it gotcha
are you guys ready
yeah
so it's just axes left right
yep okay and that's r2
got it
it's always the one that we um shoot
gotcha to get in
all right i'm in
okay
nightmares
ah all right popped it i'm trapped over
here okay yes they're up the chains are
up
okay
yeah you know i think it's only the one
yeah i think it's only the one okay uh
well in the center
no okay it spawned me in a real bad spot
sorry oh my god dude i immediately got
wrecked by bell guys yeah
where is there is no there is no timer
yeah
she's over she moves she moves and she
does stand in front of the belt oh she's
teleporting she's teleporting
kyle has been drawn what the [ __ ] she
she ran to the bell and she teleported
out of there
ah
so how do we keep we gotta keep her
right we gotta keep her
maybe we do have to kill the bell guys
real fast
so that they're activated and she can't
use them
does that make sense oh
maybe like they're they're covered in
nightmare goo right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
okay okay
okay interesting okay
it could be we couldn't dps at all
anyway because the nightmare guys kept
bopping us out of the well or whatever
right right it could be either that we
have one person on like bell duty
and just keeps extending the timer while
the other two pepper with dps or we just
do all like three bells or the one bell
or whatever and then it just like delays
enough for us to just do a normal dps
space imo first thing we should do in
there this next time is immediately all
of us concentrate on killing the bell
keeper guys yeah yeah knock them out as
fast as possible for sure and then
yeah see what also another thing i'm
realizing is we can like take our time
and kill all the ads here
i think we're letting people
accumulate up yeah yeah okay um because
now they're all dead we got exactly
sun and axis
yeah so that's gonna be uh l2 r2 okay
ready yep
uh new centurions just showed up running
okay i'm going r2
i'll go l two
okay got it
uh okay bill one
all right bell set
okay
coming
oh getting wrecked i'm here
i'm here too shoot it
okay
all right popped
all right yep
okay clear yep
holy oh my god
this is just
absurd
oh cuddles on me
okay yeah we were definitely making it
harder for ourselves by not out clearing
properly
it's the challenge mode
on my head i'm like we gotta rush we
gotta go yeah yeah it always feels like
you have to hurry the hell out of there
but i guess not
yeah at least not in this not in this
realm you know yeah not this room so
couple
sun so that's going to be l2
uh r1 okay
okay i'll grab l2
it's the right bell okay got it okay
ready
oh more ads are spun
yeah it's fine
deal with them next time okay
all right grab mine
yep got it
spells ready
i'm headed over okay
all right i'm in
i'm not quite okay go
nice nice no i got shot immediately no
sorry that's okay that's all right
that's all right i'm gonna
thank
all fine i'll
add clear
all right i popped mine i'm gonna start
at clearing two
oh my god dude i'm just
trying to chase this one [ __ ] scion
down and he's like giving me the run
around
all right
let me grab heavy okay
okay ready yep yeah
okay
i'm going for it r1 yeah okay yep cool
i'll try oh i'm getting cooked ah get
these guys run over by orbeez
bella's not active
where you at
i'm just by the middle bell gotcha oh my
covering enemies yeah yeah
throw a grenade or something
yeah i have one
you're getting blasted by this colossus
oh no we're about to get killed
damn dude sorry
no no no no you're good okay okay
wild man this [ __ ] is why old
okay
i feel like we
i was gonna say i'm pretty broke
yeah that felt that felt good
yeah
it's just more like getting and getting
cooked a little bit but
yeah it would be nice if there was a
more reliable way to
deal with that colossus i might just be
might start just dumping more rockets on
everybody and not worrying about dps so
much yeah that's kind of my thing i
think yeah
i might leave you guys to do the damage
and while i i'm mostly add clear anyway
since you guys are doing the standards
do you think the stasis turret would
[ __ ] up the bells
i don't think so if you kept it away
from them okay
you know yeah yeah if you do a little
damage to the belt it takes kind of a
lot to knock it okay okay i'm gonna i
just swapped to stasis
um because void was not working and i
have like a healing build for solar
which helps keep me alive but it doesn't
really help much in
right clearing enemies
um okay ready
yeah let's [ __ ] go
[Music]
this is this is definitely a
a challenging encounter though like it's
a workout this whole this whole dungeon
is yeah man like
that timer not in like wouldn't be that
bad if it's necessarily you know fast
timers yeah oh christ
i just got cooked all right i'm okay all
right what do we got we got
um
sun and chalice
okay
that's gonna be
r1 l2 okay
getting the bell keepers
my frame rate's taking a dive oh
i don't know what's going on
i think i got to turn the stream off one
time oh yeah for sure
okay uh ready
no not yet
sun and chocolate l2 r1
yep square i can grab our heading
all right i'll get l2
oh no the cost is going to get me
[ __ ] sorry i try to blow them up but
i think i need to get them all first
because i literally had two of them
shooting at me at once
um
god
i guess we could just keep going but uh
we could wipe because
all right never mind
one thing um so i mean it's fine if you
guys are sticking with gala horn but i
swapped to machine guns only because
those snipers were [ __ ] me up and
yeah the machine gun helped me uh clear
those scions so i'll try and
and handle that when i
since i'm hopping on uh i'm hopping on a
thing anyway i can i can still shoot
like two more scions to my left and
right just not the one diagonal for me
uh if that makes sense but i'll but i
usually try to shoot i'll try and shoot
the colossus first though
um
okay
i'm trying to rock it out the bell
ringers right away so it's just gone
yeah okay all right
it would
benefit for us to actually go stand on
the platform so we shoot the bell so we
can just get them right away yeah that's
what i that's what i've been doing on on
occasion if i'm close enough to okay
yeah i think that's a i think that's a
good call it just like okay get you
there faster so it's dogs and cup which
is what is that l1 r1
l1 r1 okay so whichever one you go to
i'll go to the opposite i'll take l1
i'll go stand on it right now okay i'm
gonna go to r1
all right two and then phil you shoot
when you're ready yep
where are you guys where where are you
yeah yeah no but i'm trying to
i'm trying to pick the belt based on
where your location is no no we'll be
fine no matter what yeah no i know it's
it's easier for me
it makes it easier to hide
okay
okay colossus is down
that other sniper's down all right i got
mine
i got mine
all right i believe the bells are set
yep bella is set
get ready go
nice very nice much better much better
okay i just need to
get some health back real quick
okay got mine
yep got mine perfect
i'm just clearing i haven't yet done the
bills yet no no worries we're gonna
start clearing two yeah i want to add
clear
all right it's a cup and sun okay
so that's gonna be uh r1l2 okay i'll go
i'll get our one perfect
i'm gonna do the left bell this time
okay
ready when you are
yep
oh stupid orbeez go away
all right bill's ready
yeah i grabbed mine
got mine
yep take us
i'm sorry i had a reload
very good
okay
all right
so what are we trying to focus on when
we go back in for dps kill the bell guys
as fast as possible right okay gotcha i
think that's the trick gotcha gotcha
i might get yeah i i dropped my thing in
though okay one sec i did not but i'm
getting cooked hey i'm just stay alive
i'm gonna go get him
got mine holy [ __ ] god it gets really
really hectic right there spelled out
it's gonna transform us if you could get
me real quick yeah i'm trying to [ __ ] me
dude all right
killing bell guys
just going toward the middle bell
oh i shot it the bell is ready to be
wrong cato was uh
i don't know man i don't know that's so
weird
that is so weird
i don't like yeah that's really annoying
um there's something to this that we're
not getting i think
at a certain point i wouldn't mind
looking it up just so we're no go ahead
i'm fine with that over and over for
sure
uh do we want to wipe here since
it's getting disastrous
heck of dead
yeah
um
okay
kill me
i popped the bell guys and i shot the
bell
um
and she was standing in front of it
but she still got away i wonder do we
like damage her enough to stagger her
maybe that's it maybe we just got a
pummeller
[ __ ] i don't know i'm i'm still confused
over the these chains because there's
four chains dude i don't think you i
think you're worried about the chains in
a way that doesn't matter because like
as soon as we shoot the chains they all
become immune and they all move and yeah
the bell thing no i think it's just any
one chain does the job you don't think
that like a section or something gives
you more dps there's not enough there's
not enough time
related to them i don't think oh whoops
i didn't know that was going to do that
yeah i didn't rally that's okay i didn't
either i didn't even drop a flag
like two steps away i'm just going to
jump off the side i couldn't find
anything at the moment uh just so i can
google them
but yeah there's
cool yeah perfect
yeah i'm super unclear i'm like
yeah phil if you don't mind helping me
look as well see if you can find
anything yeah sure let's see what reddit
says and maybe reddit's got it yeah i
would say raid secrets
interesting interesting
definitely i'm sure rate secret says
that i'm sure people are done already
oh definitely
duality secret chest
not the secret
not the secret
secret in the second encounter before
you even start one of the tours in the
wall of course raid secrets finds a
secret chest but not the mechanic
hang on um
they're on final boss is final boss what
we're doing i think so it's got to be oh
it is okay yeah in order to do dps you
have to be within the bell range
follow her around the room as she goes
to each one of the bells in random order
if you s after you stun the ball what
okay so i think i think what they're
saying
you just damage her enough
no
okay hang on okay so i think we have to
go to the bell and stand in the bell
thing and shoot the bell as she
approaches it and that will stun her and
then we can hit her
okay yeah
she's saying
uh you can get her to slow down a little
by getting her to stop you have to kill
the bell keepers to open the bell then
shoot the bell to stun her and do dps
so yeah we weren't quite quick enough
and do real dps
she'll eventually just stand another
small bell and the process repeats uh
okay so it's a day it gives you a damage
buff during dps the bells have a shadowy
radius around them
if she's in that shadowy radius she gets
stunned i'm pretty sure if you're in the
shadowy race you get the damage buff but
just be as close as
possible as you can you can bait her
stomp to buy her more buy more time for
her your team you get near the bell
before she does so she's going to pick a
bell it's going to be random we have to
get to that bell and do the the bell
shoot
maneuver that we've been doing the whole
time okay that'll give us the dps and
that should stun her for about 10
seconds and then we're gonna lay into
her so
we're gonna want
close close range
uh dps type stuff so fusions or whatever
yeah fusions shoddys
strat [ __ ]
yeah
yeah
uh i'm really i'm liking galron for
clear
for this because i was able to pop all
the bell guys super fast
but um otherwise yeah i think we're in
any other guns
so
am i the only one who's going to put
riley banner down
oh yeah
i thought we were still talking i think
that's the goal i think that the goal is
um
blast the bell guys as fast as possible
as soon as we're in because you can't
really do any
real damage to her anyway
um and then we keep an eye on her and
see where she goes try to try to get out
ahead of her yeah okay okay
um if one of do we want to have somebody
be dedicated like stop vader
while we're working on that too
just in case um maybe i'm a little
nervous about stop dating because we're
already so
weak fragile okay yeah that's fine don't
worry about it then we'll worry about
that later
but she moves real quick so yeah she
does we're gonna have to we're gonna
have to be on top of it but i'm just
gonna fill the center of the room with
rockets basically did we label the bells
at all are we just doing left middle
right left middle right okay yeah it's
fine from the stairs yeah yeah all right
it's axes and dogs okay
so that will be
l1 r2 okay i'll take l1 okay
yeah i also like stasis for this i think
that'll help
yeah
all right i am ready whenever
but i'm going to clear some ads here
uh i'm going to go to the right bell
because kyle's on the left okay
you can shoot it whenever yeah
there we go
now ready yeah nice couple of gallery
rockets just handles it yeah yeah
honestly
i feel like we've i've gotten this part
down pretty good yeah i'm good i'm good
too
let's go when you guys are ready yep
ready
axes
oh yeah sorry
did you get your dunk i got my duck nice
then yeah i got you
you wouldn't get me otherwise no i was
gonna get you anyway
it but where whether it would be better
just leave you dead and die myself right
um what are the other two cup and axes
yeah i feel like
now that we're doing full add clear the
heavy ammo is
is pretty pointed so r1r2 or one i'll
take r1 okay yeah i'm going to go to
um let's clear a little more and then
we'll do it yep okay
all right i'm ready whenever yup me too
i'm gonna shoot this one on the left
okay
fellas ready okay
heading over
wow yeah this is much easier
jesus all right i'm good
okay
okay
oh my god
i'm so dead i'm so
dead holy [ __ ]
please just bank it okay thanks mine
oh thank god nice
someone reviving though before you guys
get pulled
thank you
all right shoot the chain
get us out of here
got it
okay i'm in the middle
yep i'm gonna [ __ ] launch rockets on
these nerds yeah i got a bell keeper
here nice just going to the middle one
is going middle okay
kill this guy kill this guy kill this
guy all right shoot it shoot it
there go ahead nice job
popper
wow
don't move around don't move around
sorry all right she's going to the next
one
oh [ __ ]
shoot it shoot it
got it oh nice job
okay get her again
uh let's go to the other bell
like shoot her on your way but that way
we get the buff yep
here she comes
wait till she gets close
bless it
nice
nice
this fusion sucks i need to change
okay now she's going to go to the big
one and she's going to reset
yeah dude nice okay there we go all
right we got it we got it we got it
real quick
oh
yeah
yeah we got it geez that was pretty good
christ that was wild dude
all right yeah so
just take your time and clear because
yep
get right now
yeah
um i wonder i might flip to a slug
shotgun
yeah i definitely could use it better up
close
yeah
i'm using the raid
the vowel um
fusion and i don't love it e2 it yeah
it's not great um
it can be better it's too slow
yeah
i need like
better all right yeah so give me a sec
to swap guns before we go okay i still
need to even look at what we're uh what
we're doing
uh dogs and
uh
what is it
dogs and chalice
so that will be
uh
l1 r1 okay
all right one sec while i look at dim no
worries yeah no worries i'm picking up
some ammo there's gonna be some ads that
spawn in a bit where you are filled
though
yeah yeah okay
uh okay
i don't know
i don't really have anything i like
maybe just stick with it for now yeah
yeah i mean like it was something it
worked so i'm dead right
i'll come get you
if all these freaking scions everywhere
holy [ __ ] yeah seriously i might
actually yeah oh no too many scions
20 seconds
uh otherwise if you want to just try to
stay alive yeah
yeah
10. okay typically we don't want to try
and wait too long after we clear the ads
because yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's it's a whole lot yeah it's a new
round
that's basically
i'm back cool
i'm going to go
okay we're good
get to your spots and i'll pop the bell
just l one r one right okay yeah yep l1
r1 all right i'm gonna kill this guy i'm
going to l1
or
yeah i'm sorry i'm going r1
okay
yeah you can just take us phil
i'm out of rockets [ __ ]
oh man
we got our bells down cool
okay i'm good i didn't get the colossus
all good
just pull us
okay
yeah i need heavy ammo bad same
okay looks like it is cup and
oh lmao sorry i had a brain fart
you haven't put yours in yet yeah i
don't know oh good i was actually about
to say normally i try and put it right
away because i'm scared i'll die but
it's actually easier i think to maybe
hang back and clear yeah
yeah okay i i dunked mine though so okay
it's cupping dogs cup and dogs okay cool
yeah so uh l one oh same thing yeah l1r
one two one all right cool i'm on r1 and
ready to go i
am on l one pull one ready hey i gotta
move to a different bell okay
okay popping
okay got mine
i got mine too i might need help on the
bell guys because i got no heavy no
problem i just threw this turret down
i'd be a little rocked
uh
i'm good all good okay okay we're good
one
oh one's out okay all right other side
come over here yep
ready oh just in time go all right
okay let's place mads oh i hate when she
does that yeah
all right dunking mine
[ __ ] hell there we go
all right pop mine too
nice all right okay
uh shoot the chain yeah
yeah
okay i don't i only have one rocket this
time so i need i'm gonna need help on
bell stuff okay okay
so i'll shoot the bell into the or i'll
shoot the rocket into the center no i'll
shoot the side guys okay okay i'm
getting those guys
okay
all right i'm popping ready yep
do it do it i'm not there
all right she's stunned
nice
uh we might need to kill a couple more
play uh bell guys
okay she's moving
no okay they're clear they're clear
she come in the middle she yeah do it
ah i'm grabbing you i got you
i don't know what killed me she's gonna
start moving about three seconds three
two
one
okay
all right go
oh man
ammo is a major problem
hey that was good though yeah yeah
right yep
all right
okay
let's try and get some ammo
oh my god could i not be shot at for
like five seconds
oh my god yes give me that heavy
nice
all right
i always found some fusion ammo yeah i'm
good on emma now thankfully all right
where are we going looks like we got sun
and we got
is that cup sun and cold cup
uh which one's cup again cup is r1 sun
is l2
okay i got r1 okay i'm grabbing actually
i'm full on heavy so i'm gonna go to l2
ready to pop one your guys yeah you can
just pop it we've got ads coming in now
okay
go ahead
little toasty over here yep yep
no i got got oh sorry that's okay i got
you that sucks
uh
bella's set
all right i can at least get the one
yeah
yeah we're okay
let's take your time oh what what
happened did we run out of time
i thought we had like dude this keeps
happening it's like
nothing happens when we die i don't
understand
[ __ ] hell
oh looks like emilio and uh they all
finished
oh do they nice yeah
thanks emilio we got it we just need to
execute it now we're really man i don't
know why we i don't know why we got
those i don't know why we died there
that was really weird
anyway let's go it might have been
hopefully it wasn't like a stray
osteo
i mean i don't know why we were all
standing around it yeah
i'm curious to see how the
you said does the damage
stack with each bell like is the last
bell the strongest that we're going to
be i don't know i haven't been able to
check
um it just seems like you get a buff
yeah i think it's just full damage
each section
yeah
gotcha and it definitely sucks if you're
not there
okay
uh all right so my damage was much lower
because i wasn't there we got sun blades
yeah so uh both that are the default
twos deuce okay i got r2 okay i'll go l2
i'm ready whenever
yep
popping
okay
got mine
uh did i get them all i missed one
all right now the bell's set it's the
middle okay
lovely
yeah let's get out of here let's do it
shooting it
all right
uh if you guys need a well i'm going to
put one in the middle yep actually i'm
going to put one on the
axis
thank you
all right thanks fun
thanks mine as well
i am oh my god [ __ ] stuck in the
goddamn chances oh i see that yeah i
banked my [ __ ] though
thanks
okay we got
oh sean luke remember to i would say
remember to radius radiant us during the
dps part oh yeah i do okay good because
i forgot until i just hit the well
so r1 r2
err
no uh
yeah r1 r2 yeah
okay i'm going all right l1 um no it's
all good
popping the right bell
do it
all right got mine
got mine as well
i'm killing the bell guys
trying to save rockets all right they're
dead
all right
let's roll let's do it yep do it
oh my god
[ __ ] obnoxious
rift on
gotta axis these ads a bit it's a little
spicy
nice nice nice that stasis is great
all right
conquest is prime
uh kyle leave me alone get us out of
here
yep i'm shooting it
we're going in okay cool
ah
it's taking forever oh my god oh it
lashed me off the side
no
this sucks man do we want to wipe it or
keep going
i don't know if we could wipe if you
guys want uh no we're not gonna be able
to she's already at the other bell we
didn't even yeah
where's she at that sucks man
oh man yeah i was like off the side
that sucks
that's tough
ugh
i think she'll
well
it's hard to say but
we should pay attention to where she
goes and why dude
let's just get it okay i'm just gonna
cook oh my god
i think it was flustered because it was
like oh you're dead and looking around
and yeah it just launched me off like
when it transported me i was in the like
purple stuff yeah you can't be over
there because that is a pit
right yeah i didn't know that i was just
trying to stay alive
um but yeah pay attention if she goes
toward the like closest bell of wherever
she is because that might give us some
information
i wonder if that's what she does like
wherever she is she runs toward the
the nearest one if that makes sense no
maybe
and then we can anticipate it because we
have no idea where to go
we're just kind of guessing
i mean yeah i before when we were just
like let's just kill all of them
immediately like that worked really well
oh yeah i mean i wasn't there to do it
otherwise right exactly but i just mean
like
so we know where to get the buff at
another thing might be worth checking is
if we can pop any bell and get the buff
and not just the one that she goes to
you know
i feel like
maybe because then we could just stack
ourselves at some place
you know and i imagine just be
near it though
yeah maybe would be my thing yeah you
might be right
it might be or but it might also be like
are you talking about still popping the
bell that she's running towards or just
popping any bell and like we just pick
our own bell because if we do that
though there's what's stopping her from
still going to the bell that she's now
close oh she stands out you know but
yeah you might be right yeah um so what
is it axes and cup
uh
yes yes okay so
both the r's okay okay we'll do the
right i'm on r2
i'm on r1 go for it let's go
oh whoops barrel is set
cool i'll just grab my thing
[Music]
someone robbing a bank
yeah somebody
all right i'm good
pop it let's go
oh boy all right um axes drift here
oh thank you huge
oh my god this [ __ ] silence
that launches you yeah
yeah it's just the worst it's like it's
like the the worst cherry on top with
all the other [ __ ] going on
uh cup and
i don't see all right oh no i have to i
have to uh pop mine still oh gotcha
gotcha okay he's cupping dogs oh yeah
okay now it's cutting dogs perfect so
that's gonna be
l1 r1 that's the yeah that's the ones
i'm on l1 right now okay i'm on r1
cool i am dead god damn it that's okay i
got something hold on
i'm gonna pop to be safe
do we want to clear this wave or just go
uh they'll be here when we get back so
we might really clear them out i froze a
few of them so hopefully that helped
um
or at least get it like manageable okay
okay i'm gonna pop it
oh oh wait no i'm not i'm waiting don't
pop don't pop it yet
okay you can pop it
all right we're doing the middle bell
okay
okay got it yep
all right middle bell
oh my turn shooting the thing stay in
the middle stay in the middle
all right we're good let's get up okay
okay
rift here
thank you perfect
i kind of set this too far away though
from everything no no no no no no no no
no no
no no
no no you're okay that's okay it's like a
little sleep sound
yeah
okay
popping mine
okay pop in mine too
here we go
okay
bell is hit
we're going in
all right ready with rockets yep right
in the middle
oh my god it launched me off the [ __ ]
edge what happened what happened
dude i don't know we're doing something
i immediately blew up i don't even
understand
oh
she's on the right she's gonna go
damn dude uh so what happened to you
david i just fell off the edge the i
think the purple i was i threw a break
oh you're in the wrong area yeah okay so
i just fell off you want to reset or
i mean it's it's kind of just
well i don't know if there's a timer or
not because we did all just die we just
cleared that one time remember so maybe
we should
yeah [ __ ] it
[ __ ] it
okay
mine was weird i don't even know i like
spawned in and then just like
immediately blew up it was very weird
yeah i saw you just like
exploded i don't know get night wrecked
by geometry somehow or something yeah it
was it was very strange it's tough not
knowing if this is like
a [ __ ] up or not you know what i mean
like we can't tell if this is like being
buggy or
yeah if we're making a mistake give me a
sec i gotta swap something
also gamer time in the chat confirm that
um it has to be the bell she's near for
stunning gotcha gotcha okay good good to
know
uh
having to like
run out ahead of her is really
irritating
all right 10 seconds
all right
i'm good
give me one sec no worries
okay i'm good
sweet
i think we're all set let's do it
someone's cars getting broken into like
outside my house or some [ __ ]
so annoying
okay uh it's axes and dogs
l1 r2 okay r2
okay all right we'll do the middle bell
when you guys are set uh i am
i'm good
yup go for it
okay
that was clear got mine maybe not i
think i missed a guy
there is he's over here i got him yeah
oh i'm
hurt all right let's roll
okay i'm here go for it
go
nice
um whoa
under fire from kyle immediately i'm
gonna put a rift up here perfect
there are so many freaking scions
seriously holy crap
okay popping popped
we got i see dogs
okay
so that's gonna be uh
it's the it's the l ones r one l one r
one okay cool i'll go to r one right now
are you going r one i can go to r one
okay
all right i'm here i'm ready
uh were you not gonna clear these guys
uh
oh were there more still yeah
well now we get a refresh actually
that's good actually let's put okay
kicking out a lot of ammo okay yeah i'm
gonna do the right one okay all right go
for it
let me get off the purple [ __ ]
cool
ah
all right bell's open
it's gonna be this one over here
okay
i'm over here i'm here let's go go
nice
yeah
it's going to be top of these steps
okay
kind of close the title whatever
all right popped mine popped mine
centurions
all right bell get ready yup oh [ __ ]
okay
this room's gonna be spicy when we get
back be right be aware
she's going left
okay
okay all right
all right ready
okay
you guys are radiant
nice dude nice
oh sorry can you grab me yep
oh she popped me oh the sniper
is it middle is it metal is it metal
yeah yeah it's yes middle what's the
bless it
nice all right so yeah maybe it goes in
order at least
seems to be the case
all right she's moving
okay
do it
i got sniped
it's okay it's okay
okay good damage though oh that was
excellent damage that was perfect
that is what i'm looking for yeah that
was much better yep just a full galley
clip
yeah we can just get more nice heavy
ammo will be more ammo yeah yeah
yeah good stasis i like that
it's like a it's like a nice breather
you know yeah it's very helpful
seriously
okay uh cup and dog so it's gonna be the
ones again okay
i can get r1
it would be nice if i could get more
than one rocket though because i'm
probably gonna have to use it on the
yeah in the other room
yeah we're definitely gonna need rockets
for those bell guys yeah totally
all right let's get us out of here yeah
yeah
yeah okay middle bell
yep pull
okay
grab time
got mine too [ __ ] getting sniped
i'm so clear in bell guys
okay
middle bell i'm getting hurt though
okay
let me try and just get a
i think
yep thank you okay
all right so let me let me throw it down
where's your thing oh right right side
yeah
yeah
oh i don't have a rift okay never mind i
do
i'm a warlock too i totally forgot
wow kyle stop it
okay
all right
uh i'm going to bank mine
all right got it
oh my god there's just so many dudes
i'm coming
yeah me too i'm right behind
oh heavy bless
[ __ ] just move perfect
all right
okay you're set
yeah i just gotta get back to mine yeah
it's it's just the one right it's just
the case that's the one okay they don't
uh spawn until you get both gotcha
gotcha okay
let's do it all right popping right
it's gonna be spicy when we get back
okay
okay i got it
cool
uh yeah help me with bell keepers then
middle ones are down
two on the left right now uh the
colossus is getting me
i can't get killed okay i got killed no
[ __ ] that might be bad because we only
have three bells yeah i think that might
be why we wiped
and we're going to get bounced anyway
son of a [ __ ]
i think i think we're screwed yeah that
wiped us
yeah sorry guys i got i got wiped by
both colossus and
that's fine
that's that's just that's such a tough
yeah
unlucky roll
damn damn damn damn okay okay all right
let's do quick yeah hold on let me put
on a rocket scavenger so i can get more
um
do the rocket scaps stack i think they
do don't they i think they do
sick
you know what might also be good a
finisher
because like out of finisher mod yeah
yeah not using it well for a whole lot i
mean occasionally but right
that's actually a
great call
um
maybe
if we can get it okay
rocket launcher grenade kickstart high
energy fire taking charge
rocket launchers yeah i mean at least a
special at least give a special
ammo yeah all right
uh
okay
i'm gonna move some stuff around and
give it a try
okay
okay
gamertime says you died because you
killed the wrong bearer with osteo and
lost all your time
uh this last run
yeah or earlier i didn't have osteo this
last one i was running a hand cannon
killed the wrong bearer
it might if it's if it's talking about
the bell there was definitely a time
when um there were two dogs frozen on
the bell oh is that why and when they
yeah when they uh what do you call when
they pop there was like damage done to
the bell uh as well if that's what i
think he's talking about the standard
bearer guys the the snipers in the
nightmare if you shoot the ones that are
not the two hologram related ones then
you lose your time and it wipes you
yeah which i didn't realize okay no
those guys just sniped so that's good to
know yeah no i i
yeah no i always take him out because
i'm like i'm helping
i'm like they're [ __ ] killing us okay
then obviously yeah don't kill the
others okay that sucks
what a bastard thing okay that's fine
all right okay let's just just be wary
then okay of two snipers
being alive each time yeah just
riffs whenever possible basically
that's good to know
we
got axes and sons of the twos twos okay
i'll go l2
okay
when you guys are set i'm gonna do the
middle bell yep okay
oh my god
okay at least i uh oh my god me too i
didn't i didn't i didn't grab my thing
yet
yeah cool i uh i shot a galley right as
um the colossus things came at me just
blew my face
all right cool i got my [ __ ] now
all set
getting cooked but
ah
i'm coming i gotcha i got you let's just
get out yeah yeah come on come on come
on go go go pop
okay all right
uh
plant the thing over on the right here
yep
coming
i'm going to drop us a well okay yeah
perfect
okay axe is planted okay sun's planted
is that all of them i think so
okay it's cups and axes
or one that would be
r1r2
right now
i'm popping the right bell okay
all right i grabbed mine
got mine i'm a little slow on bills
where'd he go where'd he go
where'd he go
i missed one somewhere oh here it is
okay good
sweet ready yes let's go
okay let's try and plant it it did not
okay now it brought me that was a weird
delay
yeah
i'll put a rift over there
done that before
uh ripped on you
thank you thank you a little
spot but that's okay no no no that's
fine
i say we clear before we go yeah yeah
this is the second phase right
yeah yeah okay this would be first dps
yeah
okay
centurions
okay
it's going
rocket's ready yep don't be on the
purple okay cool
middle's ready she's going left
okay that's ready
we're good
radiant
she's going right oh okay
we still gotta get him i got him got him
okay we're good
get here
going
all right middle
got it
we didn't get the buff or i didn't
yeah so what
we have to be in the radiates when yeah
you got to be
yeah sorry no it's okay that's okay
that's okay just reel it in don't bother
wasting your money yeah no worries okay
that makes sense well it's almost half
hey that was yeah that was almost half
that's fine that was so good
no worries
i'm gonna put down a well
okay right here
nice
some heavy would be nice
yes yep as usual
as usual
every time in this game
okay it's going to be the elves because
it's sun dogs okay all right we'll do
the left bell then when we clear yeah
oh there's some heavy
all right i'll get uh
l2
oh you're getting all too okay cool i'm
going that's all one
oh
hey kyle stop shooting me please oh my
god
please pop it yeah just pop it pop it
pop it i'm not over there oh no i'm no
you're fine
i had like no cover uh
one second okay
going
it's gonna be spicy when we get back
just yeah yeah yep no worries all good
okay grab mine
got mine too i'm getting a little cooked
i need a little hand
all right
uh one more bell guy
all right we're set
yeah there's plenty of time if we're not
actually actually killing the [ __ ]
oh great
lovely rift right here
yep
okay
okay
we got sun standard bears are what sun
underneath
make these centurions come out fyi
oh that's the twos it's the twos okay
i'll go uh last spell is right
i'll go l2
i'm gonna pop it right away okay excuse
you there yeah we're here do it do it
ah
colossus
all right grab
mine got mine
killing
bell guys but i'm getting cooked
okay we're good
okay
uh get it back
okay go
all right put a riff forever i don't
have one yet actually i'm gonna well
nice thank you
risk it
all right david you can pop yours when
you need to
okay
suck
uh yup
got it
no
i got sniped [ __ ]
sorry that's a good tail guys
um
okay there is another bell we're good
we're good sick yeah we have three bells
jesus though
oh is there one oh there's the middle
one okay yeah yeah yeah okay uh we can
see whenever
all right going
god that suck they like shot me in the
back
i might die i'm getting cooked where are
you at don't die
okay i'm okay i'm okay okay
all right we're in the middle yeah one
sec
okay i'm gonna die
okay okay i'm okay
thank you thank you
i think all the bells just reset
yeah they did
i don't know what causes that because i
know at some point they aren't resetting
okay i'm just taking my time yeah yeah
yeah there's yeah no rush yeah don't die
snipers are up
oh
hey kyle like leave me alone please for
like a second
she knows she knows you have it i know
all right i'm popping it all right
and i'm activating bell cool
all right
okay middle's good just going to left
kill that battle guy all right good get
in the vicinity real quick go go go
okay okay radiant
all right she's moving
dude
it's going right it's going right okay
okay here get here get here yeah yeah
okay
pop it
nice
i wish i had rockets
right
you wear the snipers
okay middle
one sec i'm not there no worries
go okay
i know i know
don't think about it
all right all right good [ __ ] good [ __ ]
okay okay
reset
[ __ ] hell okay so
how many bells do we have
oh we have we have we have a full okay
we have a full count
oh yeah god
that's so sick
i'm gonna put a well down here okay oh
please do
oh that's a floating well okay oh hell
yeah
it's my side
scion
wow my brain
snipers
okay it's uh the twos axes and sun okay
i'll go l2
all right i got
r2 just clearing a little more
all right okay i'm good whenever i'm
good
i'm gonna get the middle okay
i'm so [ __ ] on ammo you guys
okay ah
sniper got me one set of battle guys is
down but not the other all right okay i
can get you i can get you just be
careful you're getting attacked in the
back
although we've got plenty of time mike
get these bell guys
oh colossus
all right all right
let's get the [ __ ] out of here
go go go go go
i died right there
uh okay you're right under kaido so i'm
just getting sick
yeah
yeah fine take your time no worries stay
alive
yup
i've been 30 so if you want to just wait
it out that's fine too okay
we'll just clear ads
yeah exactly 20 seconds
all right three seconds
oh just
okay
okay
i need to pop mine still axe oh okay
yeah oh yeah whatever lmao i thought we
were doing
and it'll yeah centurions to just be
ready yep okay
in fact david i'm
oh never mind we're fine
okay we got
uh sun and cup so that's gonna be r1 l2
okay i'm going r1
okay
we're going to do the left bell
all right i am ready
all right there's one centurion left but
r1 r1 oh
lmao i know my left from rights
another wave came okay uh just pop it
when you can yeah nope never mind i got
killed
okay we'll just survive the
yeah
oh dude like two heavy bricks
are there that's yeah we actually might
benefit from this to be honest yeah this
is great
oh yeah
that's what i need
oh god damn it okay okay i'm ready
david yeah
okay okay go for it
no i'm not gonna throw my galley yet
i'm just going to tank this [ __ ]
does he ever stop
dancing with this guy all right bills
are down yep got mine
uh rift is gonna be on the sun
okay
pop my riff or pop my son
holy [ __ ] dude
yeah a little rough right here oh boy
maybe the bell guys show up behind us
and once it gets a little less spicy
it's just spicy everywhere
that's right holy crap
you guys okay do you should we throw the
well
uh i'm okay i'm okay okay now yeah all
right okay just give me a sec
a little bit
yeah that's what i wanted to hear you
guys are okay
all right i'm popping mine put yours in
yeah all right
morse insurance
i'm activating the bell
get ready okay
she's going left again okay i'm there i
already activated it
all right i mean it's clear just pop it
up oh good good wait wait okay
yeah uh the other bell keepers are not
dead are they um i think the one on the
right mine's dead one on the right
actually
[ __ ] lay into her [ __ ] this yeah
i wasn't even paying attention to the
[ __ ]
actually just [ __ ] lay in order
[Laughter]
got two kinetic weapons
breathe
breathe
[Laughter]
i got two different
ones again
all right i got the machine gun
nice
oh my god that was
that was a lot
that was fun
that was fun
it was very fun man i'm taking i'm
taking a moment just to breathe a little
bit per aeris is uh for the doctor's
instructions
jesus christ that was sick man
yeah good times
anything in here
we got 20 seconds run around
oh could we go in the back
we can
is this the area where oh this is the
trophy room right tribute
yeah yeah nice
very cool very cool
oh my god all right let's
see the triumphs
uh
oh triumphs yes
oh did we
oh hell yeah
what did we get oh my god we got the
clan one complete all encounters the
full fire team entertainments oh nice
hell yeah
gotta love that
nice
oh wow okay so this is cool if you do
stuff like the master run uh-huh or a
solo run or
uh find
all the oh you hit your
memories yeah it increases the drop rate
of the exotic oh that's so
the good news is that that happens the
bad news is that it's rng
yeah
let's see what i got man i got oh you
switched off solar so we didn't get the
solar one oh yeah that's okay
uh we got plenty of time to do it yeah
yeah there are a lot of raid raid style
ones in here that's cool
yeah that's cool find all the memories
there are a lot of them
we found three
or i did
yeah how many were there total
there are five
two three four five ten twelve jesus
yeah wow like uh that's like grasp right
yeah similar to grass
[ __ ] man
we missed a bunch in the beginning okay
cool great good
excellent good times
oh i think i pulled the
what did i get the sub
off that last encounter
golden tricorn demolitionist
with the tonneau range
nice stability sucks though that's
unfortunate
cool i guess uh
back to the regular workday then huh
i guess
uh yeah cool
good run guys uh stream out dude
thanks for coming with us
all those who are watching
i suppose
are we still on i don't even remember
[Laughter]
i don't know
well cool oh i've been muted i was just
uh congratulating everyone
that's so funny um i'm saying you can't
hear you
yeah yeah i was saying that uh that zach
and meals were
in chat giving us all their energy and
nice that's probably why we won but
yeah man so i'm probably gonna end the
stream thank you chad for joining us
that was an excellent excellent morning
and afternoon had a lot of fun
uh
yeah good times enjoy the rest of your
friday and enjoy your weekend we're
gonna sign off peace
thanks y'all
bye bye
you